welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday
[Music]
life I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a
professor of neurobiology and
Opthalmology at Stanford School of
Medicine my guest today is Dr Michael
Eisenberg Dr Michael Eisenberg is a
medical doctor specializing in urology
and an expert in male sexual function
and fertility he is both a clinician who
sees patients as well as a research
scientist have having published over 300
peer-reviewed articles on male sexual
function Urology and fertility and he is
considered one of the world's foremost
experts in male sexual health today we
discuss a broad range of topics
important to all men including erectile
dysfunction and function we also discuss
prostate health and urinary Health we
discuss fertility and sperm count we
discuss even topics seemingly esoteric
such as why penile lengths are actually
increasing over time while sperm count
seem to be decreasing today you'll also
learn some very interesting surprises
such as the fact that a very very small
percentage of erectile dysfunction
actually stems from hormone dysfunction
rather the vast majority of erectile
dysfunction stems from issues that are
either vascular that is related to blood
flow or neural and today you'll learn
about a large variety of treatments for
erectile dysfunction Dr Eisenberg also
dispels a lot of common myths that you
hear out there both on the internet and
in popular culture that relate to male
sexual health and function by the end of
today's episode I assure you that you
will have a thorough understanding of
what male sexual health is how it
relates to other aspects of health and
how to think about treating maintaining
and improving all aspects of male sexual
health fertility and function before we
begin I'd like to emphasize that this
podcast is separate from my teaching and
research roles at Stanford it is however
part of my desire and effort to bring
zero cost to Consumer information about
science and science related tools tools
to the general public in keeping with
that theme I'd like to thank the
sponsors of today's podcast our first
sponsor is Roa Roa makes eyeglasses and
sunglasses that are of the absolute
highest quality the company was founded
by two All-American swimmers from
Stanford and everything about Roa
eyeglasses and sunglasses were designed
with performance in mind I've spent a
lifetime working on the biology of the
visual system and I can tell you that
your visual system has to contend with
an enormous number of challenges in
order for you to be able to see clearly
Roa understands this and as design
glasses both for sport and for wearing
in casual settings or to work or to
dinner that always allow you to see with
Crystal Clarity their ey glasses are
extremely lightweight and they won't
slip off your face even if you get
sweaty I wear Roa sunglasses when I'm
driving into direct sunlight or when
it's particularly bright during the
middle of the day if you'd like to try
Roa eyeglasses or sunglasses go to Roa
that's
r.com and enter the code huberman to
save 20% off your first order again
that's Roa r.com and enter the code
huberman at checkout today's episode is
also brought To Us by eight sleep eight
sleep makes Smart mattress covers with
cooling Heating and sleep tracking
capacity I've spoken many times before
in this podcast about the fact that
getting a great night's sleep really is
the foundation of mental health physical
health and performance one of the key
things to getting a great night's sleep
is to make sure that the temperature of
your sleeping environment is correct and
that's because in order to fall and stay
deeply asleep your body temperature
actually has to drop by about 1 to 3°
and in order to wake up feeling
refreshed and energized your body
temperature actually has to increase by
about 1 to 3° with eight sleep you can
program the temperature of your sleeping
environment in the beginning middle and
end of your night it has a number of
other features like tracking the amount
of rapid eye movement and slow wave
sleep that you get things that are
essential to really dialing in the
perfect night's sleep for you I've been
sleeping on an eights Sleep mattress
cover for well over two years now and it
has greatly improved my sleep I fall
asleep far more quickly I wake up far
less often in the middle of the night
and I wake up feeling far more refreshed
than I ever did prior to using an eights
Sleep mattress cover if you'd like to
try eights sleep you can go to
8sleep.com
huberman to save $150 off their pod
three cover eight sleep currently ships
to the USA Canada UK select countries in
the EU and Australia again that's
8sleep.com
huberman and now for my discussion with
Dr Michael Eisenberg Dr Eisenberg
welcome thank you good to be here I've
been looking forward to talking to you
for a long time because these days we
hear a lot about
the diminishing quality of sperm which
in some way seems to be tacked to the
conversation about diminishing quality
of environment
people intelligence you know there's a
lot woven into this statement that sperm
quality is declining and some of it I
think people assume is related to
environmental changes some of it I think
people assume it are related to changes
in Behavior years so maybe less exercise
less sunlight who knows hopefully you'll
tell us what's really going on but the
first question I have is is sperm
quality actually declining and
regardless what is sperm quality yeah
great question so I think it's very
controversial I think as your question
alludes to so I think we'll start by
just talking about what sperm quality is
and why it's important so for
reproduction as you've covered on the
podcast before a man makes semen um and
that has sperm in it and so when we're
talking clinically about a semen
analysis there's a few things we look at
we look at the amount of ejaculate semen
that comes out we look at the sperm how
many there are we look at their motility
or Movement we look at their morphology
or shape there's some more advanced
testing that's done in rare cases
looking at like fragmentation of DNA for
example or there's some newer tests
looking at epigenetic profiles of sperm
uh but essentially these are all markers
or fertility so fertility in itself is a
team sport right so it's hard to you
know M label a man as fertile or not
fertile without knowing about his
partner um but nevertheless based on
different these different parameters we
try and quantify How likely a man is to
be able to achieve a pregnancy so the
World Health Organization every decade
or so looks over the existing literature
and defines these different cut points
of what's normal or what's subfertile uh
for those levels so that's sort of the
backdrop of what Seaman is and how you
know these these tests are done or you
know what these tests represent now the
question of whether they've declined
over time um has been you know a
question for a number of years there was
a landmark paper in the early 90s by
Carlson and a group in Denmark that
showed this temporal decline you know
over the last 50 years from that time
point and so what the investigators had
done is looked over the literature for
studies that reported semen quality
around the world and noted that you know
the quality in the earliest studies like
in kind of the mid uh 20th century were
here and then over time they had sort of
declined the more recent studies um now
that study was very controversial there
was questions about waiting from
different studies putting because you
can imagine these there's not a lot of
early studies so putting a lot more
importance on those rather than some of
the later ones um and so since then
there's been many other studies that
have that have come out in time and even
today it remains very controversial I
think you know if I were to say that I
believe there's a decline some of my
colleagues and friends would be very
upset with me if I say I don't believe
it some of my colleagues and friends
would be very upset with me so I would
say that you know my opinion really
varies based on Whose paper I've read
and I there's some very convincing you
know studies uh on each side of it you
know there most recently just in the
last year or so there was a meta
analysis of you know tens of thousands
of men where they looked at again a host
of these studies over the last uh number
of decades all around the globe so prior
studies who really just focused on the
Western Hemisphere Western countries
because there was more data from that
but more recently we've gotten a lot of
data from Africa from Asian countries as
well uh and those also support this
decline um so you know one of the
counterarguments to why we're seeing
that is just sort of an evolution of
techniques over time um so that's one of
the the sort of the popular um questions
about whether there's really a true
decline um you know I think as you're
alluding to why there would be decline
is also you know unknown and but you've
sort of labeled you know perfectly the
kind of most common hypotheses so
whether there some environmental
exposures right a lot of things have
changed over the last 50 years and I
think you know chemical exposure is
certainly one of those and there have
been some fairly convincing you know
pre-clinical studies so you know mostly
done in animals uh that show that like
exposure to different chemicals thetes
um or BPA other things may actually harm
you know reproductive function for men
and for women as well uh and so it may
be that you know these chemicals you
know that are that we're being exposed
to as kids and adults or even probably
um more sinisterly when we're um you
know kind of developing in utero that
may be kind of the most harmful exposure
um but there's also been you know an
obesity epidemic as well and there's a
strong link between a men man's
reproductive function um and body weight
and so that's also um to play a role in
some of this too um so I think there are
convincing studies but the other I guess
aspect to this is that there's
variations in semen quality around the
country and around the world there's
Geographic variation and so that's also
sort of an unknown um uh explanation uh
you know there could be different sort
of genetic you know compositions of men
and so there's different reproductive
potential in that Source there could be
different environmental exposures diet
exercise lifestyle and there's a famous
stud study um done a number of years ago
where they looked at se quality among
fathers so these are men that had
achieved a pregnancy and at the first
you know prenatal visit they had um the
fathers give a seaman sample and so this
was done in four centers around the
country I think it one in California
there was um I think one in the midwest
uh there was one in New York so they
basically found that steam inequality
was sort of highest in the urban centers
in New York tended to be the highest
numbers where was you know lower in the
Midwest and so the hypothesis was
potentially because it was a more rural
setting maybe there was pesticide
exposure and that had led to these lower
numbers but you know another equally
plausible explanation may be that you
know different sort of a different
population and maybe you know that that
could explain these differences so I
think it's it's you know very important
um and I think you know one of the sort
of lacking things in this is there's not
really longitudinal data one of the
greatest things would be if we just
started tracking um seen quality around
the country just like we do obesity like
you know n Hayes cdc's uh survey of
Health in in the us if we added seen
quality onto that that way you could
really see you know how it varies around
the country and you know sort of compare
like to like to see over time if there's
really this progression you know one of
the only studies to do that in Denmark
um that started around you know around
2000 and track Seaman quality among um
you know volunteers that came in when
they were conscripted for military
service in Denmark they were offered the
opportunity to participate in this study
um and so some men did and what they
found is actually that se quality was
fairly uniform over about 20 years where
they had data but sort of another very
interesting part of that study is that
only about a quarter of those men had
normal Seamon quality um so it sort of
very concerning you know it was I guess
reassuring that it wasn't further
declining but very concerning that only
a quarter of Danish men had you know
normal semen quality and they're one of
the I think thought leaders in this
field um just because sort of a
reproductive of Crisis there you
mentioned that some of this apparent
decline in seaming quality might be
related to the fact that the tools to
measure seaming quality are getting
better and better and that would make
sense if for instance one is just
looking at total volume morphology which
means shape I should have clarified that
um how many forwardly motile sperm there
are and then also adding in you know a
very sensitive measure such as um DNA
fragmentation you know as the
instruments get finer and finer you
discover more and more details and if
you are um rating quality along a number
of different dimensions then it would
make sense that those would tear out
into different levels so if one were to
Simply ask for couples who want to get
pregnant and assuming that egg quality
is not the
issue what percentage of failures to
achieve successful pregnancy are the
consequence of
deficient sperm deficient in any way and
is that number increasing over time yeah
so I think that's really key I think
when couples think about fertility
usually it's thought of as a female
problem um and I think there's just
historic reasons for that you know if
you look at data in the US when couples
do seek care for fertility the man has
bypassed probably a third of the time
even though when you look at the reasons
for infertility man contributes probably
half of the time to infertility so I
think a half half yeah so I think
there's a huge need just to understand
and evaluate the man and one of the
reasons for this I think is that um you
know one of the main treatments for
infertility in the US is IVF which is
very powerful I think one of the you
know greatest marvels of medicine in
probably the last you know quarter
century is our ability to mix a sperm
and egg in a dish and create a life it's
really remarkable but because it now
takes just a single sperm you know
through something called iny plasmic
sperm injection where you can inject one
egg or one sperm into an egg you know
the bar has gone down dramatically you
know if a couple's just trying without
you know any assistance probably need 20
to 40 million moving sperm but now with
you know these remarkable techniques you
just need one sperm um and so because of
that you know I think a lot of our
Innovation and research on male
fertility has probably gone to the
Wayside just because clinically you know
we just need you know a few dozen sperm
for most
couples what about testosterone levels
are those also declining we hear this um
and when I look at the literature I can
find evidence for that but the question
is also whether or not the amount of
decline in testosterone levels is
significant in a way that impacts let's
say fertility but also um Vitality in
other ways energy mood um Sexual Health
Etc U what's the story with testosterone
levels are they indeed declining on
average across the male population
in the US and elsewhere I think there is
pretty convincing evidence that that is
happening and I think the reason for
that again is probably not certain but
you know there have been you know some
pretty nicely designed cohort studies
where they've recruited you know men in
the the 2000s the '90s the 80s and you
can see that depending on when these men
are recruited just you know matching age
for age these testosterone levels tend
to be lower um and then enh Hanes which
is again this sort of longitudinal study
run by the CDC um that is o shown
looking at testosterone levels over you
know decades the testosterone levels
have declined over time um so there you
know chemical exposure is one possible
explanation again either in adult or
adolescent life or in utero um but
obesity I think is also sort of a
convincing explanation is we're more
sedentary um you know we get bigger
that's one of the places that
testosterone can decline I think there's
different sort of explanations for that
um you know as testosterone's produced
it's aromatized in U peripheral tissue
you know fatty tissue fat has a lot of
this aromat taste so that converts
testosterone to estrogen so it
necessarily you know lowers the
testosterone level that's circulating in
our body um also just insulating the the
testicles our thighs get bigger
insulating the testes can also sometimes
lower the efficiency of production a
little bit too because of heat effects
because of heat effects yeah I was going
to ask about this later but I'll ask
about it now since we're talking about
heat effects and um sperm and
testosterone um The Heat Of course being
not good for um sperm health and
testosterone which is I've read a
metaanalysis I don't know um how high
quality it is but um that explained that
there is some evidence for um either
heat effects or possibly non-heat
related effects of cell phone you know
smartphone in the pocket impairing sperm
Health maybe even testosterone levels
now you hear this more often often in
kind of bioh hacky um I don't know uh
circles um which you know I'm not a fan
of the word biohacking um ites it's not
clear what it means but it it it sounds
like it means something about taking a
shortcut using one thing for a purpose
it wasn't intended but you know it also
makes sense to me that a smartphone
could generate some heat um some
radiation that might impair um
testicular function and therefore impair
sperm quality and or testosterone levels
but is there any real solid data that
carrying your cell phone in your pocket
let's assume on that the cell phone is
on is bad for sperm health or
testosterone levels yeah so um I think
there's not convincing evidence that
it's going to help um testosterone
levels I think that you know it's G to
hurt testosterone it's not going to hurt
yeah so I should you know make clear
that I think that in terms of production
and heat effects you know sperm
production is much more sensitive than
testosterone prodction production um but
there have been some studies looking at
cell phone exposure because again you're
getting this whether it's heat whether
it's sort of the you know radio
frequency you know waves coming in I
think you could posit sort of different
explanations of why that may be harmful
so there have been some studies that you
know looked early on you know men that
Ed cell phones more or less they had
lower semen quality if they used it more
but you can also imagine there's huge
differences in men that do and do not
use cell phones so you know it's it's
it's a hard experiment to design but
there been some studies uh doing this in
vitro so in the laboratory so taking you
know sperm in a cup basically and
putting a cell phone next to it or not
next to it to try and see if that played
a role there have been studies done
where they um sort of normalized the the
heat you know they kind of put on um
sort of a special stage so that it's not
heat necessarily but maybe it's RF
exposure so those studies I think don't
show sort of a me a clinically
meaningful change but there have been
some studies that say that maybe DNA
fragmentation of sperm can go up a
little bit if there's close proximity uh
to a cell phone um so I think you know
when patients ask me that which is a
common question I get in clinic
obviously patients are coming in they
want to do you know whatever they can um
to try and improve their chances um so I
think generally I think the data is not
convincing um but you know if it's easy
enough certainly to be aware of it you
know I think putting a laptop on a desk
rather than in your lap I think for heat
exposure is probably the biggest thing
that we want to
minimize about a year and a half ago I
did an episode about testosterone and
estrogen where it's manufactured in the
male and female body Etc and I found a
very interesting graph in a uh textbook
on U behavioral Endocrinology by a guy
named Randy Nelson who I happen to know
through the field of Behavioral
Endocrinology as it's typically studied
in animals so most of that book centers
on animal studies but there's a a
fraction of the studies that Center on
human uh data and there was a very
interesting graph that showed
testosterone levels as a function of age
in males um and as one might expect
testosterone levels were on average much
higher in late teens early 20s 30s and
there was a progressive decline but what
was remarkable to me about that graph is
that even when exploring the um the
Scatter Plots because they showed
individual points they didn't just show
the averages of testosterone levels in
men in their 50s 60s 7s 80s even 90s
there were these outliers these guys who
had testosterone levels that were on par
with uh testosterone levels of men in
their 30s but these guys were in their
50s 60s 7s 80s even 90s so do you
observe this clinically Do You observe
that um men are coming in you know a who
are older than 40 and have testosterone
levels and presumably free testosterone
levels as well um that are still very
high you know and the reason I asked
this is I think we've all been told and
we presume that testosterone levels
decline with age and one would expect
some outliers and of course we don't
know whether or not those guys in their
90s who have the testosterone levels of
that match the averages of men in their
30s didn't have even greater
testosterone levels in their 30s but
given that they were sealing out around
900 nanograms per deciliter you know
toward the high-end normal depending on
the scale um in already at age 90 it's
kind of hard to imagine that earlier
they're walking around with you know
2,000 nanogram per deiler testosterone
so do you see this are there some is
there just a lot of natural variation in
testosterone levels of men who walk into
the clinic at any age and of course what
is special about these individuals that
are you know maintaining high normal
testosterone levels into their uh later
years yeah that's a great question I
think this is such a common question
anytime we talk about testosterone I
think anytime we talk about most sort of
uh clinical tests that we do you know
what is average what is normal um so we
do see great variation I mean I think
just like you're saying I usually let
everybody know that you know usually
testosterone peaks you know kind of
early 20s and it tends to go down
probably 1% a year forever uh but there
are people that have very you know very
very high levels I you know just
mirroring you know that graph that you
describe I certainly have patients you
know we screen for testosterone levels
you know when patients come in with
complaints or we're worried about that
low energy level you know low libido
some of the symptoms of low testosterone
sexual dysfunction and you know to my
surprise sometimes these men you know
I've seen 80-year-olds that certainly
have the highest testosterone level I'll
see you know for 6 months um you know
why that is I think is not certain maybe
it has to do with you know I think with
everything there's probably sort of a
bell-shaped curve and everybody's a
little bit different um but Androgen
sensitivity you know sensitivity of the
receptor you know they make it more
efficiently but I have not really
noticed again because at least in
clinical practice you know when patients
come in they come in with a complaint
and so even men you know with very high
levels they may have some of the same
dysfunction men with low levels so I
think with low levels you can try and
treat that and that may be the solution
but for men with you know these what we
would consider high levels um you know
there may be other issues going
on let me frame the question I was going
to ask a little bit differently when
someone comes into your clinic and you
measure their testosterone levels as you
mentioned they're likely coming in
because they have some issue prostate
issue sexual function issue
Etc but you do get a read on their you
know s morphology of their body right so
you could visibly determine whether or
not they're likely to be obese or not um
regardless of age so earlier you
mentioned obesity as a risk factor for
lowering testosterone and sperm quality
you mentioned that fat aromatizes
testosterone into estrogen so that's at
least one mechanism by which that could
happen but if you were to just step back
and say okay if somebody who walks into
my clinic tends to be um let's say
healthier looking you know not obese
let's just put the cut off at what you
would presume is obese um is there a
higher probability that their
testosterone levels are going to be
within normal range conversely when
somebody walks in and their
obese do you fully expect their
testosterone levels to be
subnormal um or are you sometimes seeing
obese people walking in with you know
high testosterone um and the reason I'm
asking this is not to create confusion
is that I think that everybody out there
who's thinking about sperm quality and
testosterone levels and this uh apparent
decline trying to figure out you know
okay what can we do in order to maintain
the health metrics that are going to of
course increase fertility but for those
that don't want to have kids or already
have kids are going to at least maintain
or improve Vitality is obesity really
the thing to avoid so is there a not one
for one but is there a tight correlation
between obesity and testosterone levels
I would say that you cannot predict I
think that sort of would be the
take-home and so I think that you know
more information is always better you
know when I see patients in clinic um
you know some patients are walking
around you know with everything is
totally normal they're very healthy all
the numbers come in at the normal range
but sometimes when men you know look
totally normal they talked about taking
care of their life they exercise you
know five seven days a week their
testosterone levels can be very low so
even despite you know having what we
would consider should really give them
you
know symptoms um they're able to
compensate you know maybe they've lived
their whole life in that they don't know
what normal is now we get them you know
to sort of normal levels a lot of times
they feel better again because they have
no idea how they should feel um but I
think that that's just sort of important
that everybody you know should be
screened I think that you know
testosterone seman quality they've been
shown to even be barometers of Health um
so you know men with lower testosterone
levels of higher risk of you know heart
disease diabetes mortality the same
studies exist for semen quality as well
um and you know again they may have sort
of a similar relationship and
explanation why that may be but I think
it's hard to just predict you know based
on appearance what you know Testo will
be what seam equality be what testicular
function will be without actually
getting some objective data and actually
if you look at the trend of test of seam
in quality decline over time kind of
getting back to some of those earlier
points you're making if you were to
Overlay that on the known association
between
obesity um its effects on SE quality
that actually doesn't explain the whole
decline because the you know the
purported decline in seam quality is
about 50% but if you just if you were to
say well what would we expect if you
know we look at you know because we were
able to track exactly how much fatter we
are now than we used to be that actually
only explains about a 10% decline so I
think there is you know to your point
something more um and it is not
something that you can just identify by
eye what are the dos and don'ts as it
relates to I don't want to use the word
optimizing it's gotten me into trouble
before because the word optimize or
optimal suggests that there's an perfect
number that one should all attain if
possible but in reality um optimal is a
day-to-day thing um at least but what
should people avoid in order to get
their sperm quality as high as possible
their testosterone level again here I
have to be careful I don't want to say
as high as possible because some people
might not want excessive Androgen um but
at the high end of normal perh would be
the ideal for many
people what should people do what should
they avoid and here I'm setting aside
any prescription clinical treatments
that such as testosterone injections or
things like uh chonic gatr human coron
and gatot Trope and things we can talk
about a little bit later but what should
every male be doing in order to optimize
these Health parameters yeah so I think
that there are some risk factors that we
do like we'll start with steam in
quality so we talked about heat I think
that's a big one so like hot tub saunas
try and avoid those some you know light
data on seat warmers anytime you know we
kind of get this external heat source to
the scrotum you know the testicles are
outside the body because they need to be
a little cooler so anything that warms
them up can certainly be a problem could
I just briefly interrupt there um to ask
we've done episodes on sauna and some of
the health benefits of sauna um is it
sufficient for somebody to bring in a
cold pack to the sauna and put that in
their groin I actually have suggested
that that's actually what I do when I go
into the sauna um and I have suggested
this on podcasts um not just for people
who are trying to conceive because it
seems like heat as you mention is bad
for sperm not quite as bad for
testosterone levels but is it also true
that heating the testicle too much is
generally bad for endocrine function in
males and therefore would if one is
going to go into a hot sauna for 20
minutes or more to essentially cool the
the scrotal area yeah I mean I think the
spermatogenesis or sperm production is
certainly a lot more sensitive you know
whether you can sort of thwart the
effects of external heat with a cooling
pack I think it makes sense there are
studies that have looked at different
ways to cool the scrotum and have
compared you know semen quality before
and after and there's some data that may
help um it just depends how long you're
going to spend in the sauna and how cold
you know that pack is going to remain so
ice pack and in the sauna for 20 to 45
minutes and is the ice pack still cold
afterwards yeah yeah they actually sell
and by the way I have no relationship to
any of these companies but they actually
sell cold packs that are designed to be
worn in your short so if you go to a you
know I'll go to a Russian B every once
in a while now I guess I'm outing myself
yes I have a yes I have a cold pack in
my shorts when I go to the Russian B um
but um but they have a a sort of an
insulation so that you're the cold the
very cold surface is cold enough but
it's not right up in contact with the
scrotal skin because that could get um I
want to make a bad joke and say it could
get sticky uh that situation you you
don't want it get being so cold that it
actually would stick to the skin and
then it could potentially damage the
skin when you try to remove the cold
pack so it has a thin insulating layer
um and uh yeah that's essentially what
it is yeah I mean frostbite to the
scrotum is not theoretical it could
certainly happen so you do want to be
careful so I mean in theory that should
be that should be adequate to sort of
you know to decrease the risk of that
particular effect um you know I keep
coming back to health how important that
is to maintain um you know know adequate
sperm production because I think these
two are very linked you know there have
been studies that show that men with
more com morid conditions so obesity
hypertension hyper lipidemia as these
sort of Stack Up we see a decline in
testicular function so lower
testosterone levels and lower sperm
quality so I think you know taking
ownership of your your health I think is
important as well um you know a lot of
times um fertility tends to be one of
the first touch points that some men
have with Healthcare you know because
generally what brings men to the doctor
it's usually pain or you know kind of a
problem um so you know if men are in
their 20s and 30s getting ready to start
a family or 40s in some cases sometimes
they haven't you know seen a primary
care doctor so some of these things some
of this relationship has not been
established yet so I think you know
thinking about ways to start that I
think would be important too um and then
I know you don't want to talk about
testosterone but testosterone is
actually a fairly common problem that we
see in fertility clinics um I would say
that you estimat say maybe about one in
20 infertile men are that way because of
testosterone
so I think when you know people get
testosterone different places and
hopefully you know whatever provider
you're getting it from tells you that
one of the side effects of this um is
lower sperm production it's actually
been tested as a contraceptive and you
know with some other agents it can
actually be fairly effective so we just
want to make sure that you know if men
are starting testosterone they're doing
it for the right reasons and they're
doing it safely I think talking about
testosterone replacement therapy
although as we were talking about before
we started recording I I am really on a
push now to rename what people call trt
testosterone replacement therapy because
indeed some people have low testosterone
and need it replaced the r in trt but I
think what you're referring to if I'm
not mistaken is that there are probably
Millions yeah of young men and older men
taking exogenous testosterone injections
creams pills pellets you know any number
nasal sprays now you know any number of
different routes of delivery of
exogenous um testosterone and that um
dramatically reduces one's endogenous
testosterone production and dramatically
reduces one's sperm count and maybe even
quality we'll maybe talk about this a
little bit later but maybe even can
there there's I've been told that it can
perhaps introduce a DNA
fragmentation uh within the remaining
viable sperm as well so do I have that
correct you're saying that that you see
one 120 men have issues with fertility
because they are taking testosterone
right so their testosterone levels
presumably are going to be highend
normal or more but they are doing
presumably not testosterone replacement
therapy but they're doing what I call
testosterone augmentation therapy
meaning they were somewhere in the 300
to 900 nanograms per deciliter
range but decided to start taking
testosterone
anyway and then their their sperm count
essentially diminishes to nil or close
to it in some cases yeah so I mean I
think there's various reasons you would
take test I think you know some people
have been treated you know years ago and
so they do need to replace testosterone
you know um but some people do it for
augmentation I just usually say
testosterone therapy just so it you kill
the R I like that that's better than the
t a which doesn't S very good okay just
testosterone therapy yeah okay but if
you had you know for example we take 100
of my infertile patients that come in to
seei in clinic at least five of those
men will be infertile because they're on
testosterone therapy and some of them do
you know have that suspicion they say
you know I'm going to level with you
this is why my levels are probably low
but a lot of men were not told that you
know when they started therapy so I
think certainly for Reproductive age men
that's a very important conversation to
have um because there can be some other
you know ways that we kind of maintain
sperm production I think sperm cry
preservation is a good option for these
men as well um or there may be other
therapies they can think about just
because of reproductive toxicity what
about um HCG human chonic gatot Trope
and I hear about a lot of people who go
on testosterone therapy who take HCG
every other day or so um typically the
dosages that I hear about because people
write to me about this stuff all the
time really it's one of the most
commonly asked questions um I get many
questions about many topics but I would
say a full 10 to 20% of them are about
um penises or
testosterone um those is perfect then
right exactly um
so a number of those um guys who are
taking
testosterone will be prescribed HCG to
um stimulate sperm production um
endogenous sperm production to maintain
um healthy sperm presumably because they
either want to conceive or are intending
to conceive in the future is that the
best line of treatment for maintaining
fertility while people are taking
testosterone therapy yeah that's one of
the therapies that we use and I think it
can work well you know just a low dose
um usually again for those that that
know 500 to 1,000 units every other day
is usually
adequate as we all know quality
nutrition influences of course our
physical health but also our mental
health and our cognitive functioning our
memory our ability to learn new things
and to focus and we know that one of the
most important features of highquality
nutrition is making sure that we get
enough vitamins and minerals from
highquality unprocessed or minimally
processed sources as well as enough
probiotics and prebiotics and fiber to
support basically all the cellular
functions in our body including the gut
microbiome now I like most everybody try
to get optimal nutrition from Whole
Foods ideally mostly from minimally
processed or non-processed Foods however
one of the challenges that I and so many
other people face is getting enough
servings of high quality fruits and
vegetables per day as well as fiber and
probiotics that often accompany those
fruits and vegetables that's why way
back in 2012 long before I ever had a
podcast I started drinking ag1 and so
I'm delighted that ag1 is sponsoring the
huberman Lab podcast the reason I
started taking ag1 and the reason I
still drink ag1 once or twice a day is
that it provides all of my foundational
nutritional needs that is it provides
insurance that I get the proper amounts
of those vitamins minerals probiotics
and fiber to ensure optimal mental
health physical health and performance
if you'd like to try ag1 you can go to
drink a1.com huberman to claim a special
offer they're giving away five free
travel packs plus a year supply of
vitamin D3 K2 again that's drink a1.com
huberman to claim that special offer
so if somebody is not taking
testosterone exogenously they gotten
their um body fat level down to a point
where they're not considered obese so
they're hopefully doing some
cardiovascular exercise each week maybe
doing some sport or some resistance
training too um uh with the intention of
maintaining all around good
health Stave off you know
cerebrovascular cardiovascular issues
what are some of the other don'ts um I'm
going to assume that smoking cigarettes
or vaping cigarettes is bad there any
studies that have looked specifically at
vaping and sperm quality or testosterone
levels um and is there any evidence that
uh smoking cigarettes is good for
testosterone levels or sperm production
because I'm guessing the answer is no I
feel like nowadays we just say don't
smoke um but the data or the data who
knows maybe nicotine can help sperm I
have no idea right uh it's possible I
don't think we have the data on that yet
but yeah I mean I think like to your
point I think lifestyle factors are
certainly a big one and you know some of
these you know potentially um you know
kind of unhealthy habits so smoking is
certainly something you should not do
there have been you know lots of studies
that do link that to you know lower
quality again all the different measures
that we look at um also looking at
fertility these men tend to have longer
time to get pregnant um alcohol I think
is another very common question get
asked as well and I think for that
there's you know I think less of a
strong Association that we've seen so
there um you know there have been some
studies that show that very high levels
of alcohol and I guess that's sort of
subjective what some would consider
higher or not but you know when you get
above maybe 20 drinks a week there have
been some effects but usually a lot of
drinking I would think that's a lot yeah
but some people don't but yeah I did an
episode on alcohol I think anything more
than two I know people are gonna um you
know bulk at this but you know I think
any more than two drinks per week it's
where you start to see some negative
effects on some health parameters but
you know I'm I'm not a tea toddler so
you know yeah um but when you get to
this 20 drink that's when we started to
see some effects on Cen quality but the
you know the thing about that is that
usually if these men are drinking 20
they're doing other things too smoking
there can be other drug use as well so
it's hard to tease that out but in
general that's you know I think
certainly anything in moderation is
probably you know is probably better and
so that's how I counsel patients I think
again it's very rare that I see men that
are at that level but I certainly let
them know when I do um there's some new
data coming out of that we've started to
work on looking at if there are
different sensitivities to alcohol so
you know some East Asians have a
mutation that leads to Flushing um and
so that may put those men at higher risk
when they mix alcohol we may see some
you know slightly lower uh sperm
parameters you mean skin flushing
because they don't make alcohol
dehydrogenates is idea yeah um and is it
I've heard about that in Asian cultures
is there um an Asian population excuse
me but is there any evidence that other
populations might have slight variance
on alcohol dehydr enas that perhaps
maybe they don't lack it Al together but
they have I don't know um they're
hypomorphs for whatever Gene makes
alcohol dehydrogenase and therefore they
don't metabolize it as well and
therefore the toxic form of alcohol is
active in their system longer is there
any evidence for that no I think you're
exactly right I mean I think the one
that we think about is East Asian
cultures where it can be you know
depending on you know the region like um
Chinese Taiwanese probably about 40 to
50% of population has you know mutation
in the alh2 gene U but other populations
um in people of African ancestry there's
a rate of mutation I think not going to
remember the exact percentage but I
think a few percentage points is some um
individual with Hispanic ancestry
ashkanazi Jewish ancestry so in this
particular Gene there's a mutation not
the same one that East Asians have but
you know again I think it gets to why
mutation you know where we see sort of
negative effects would persist and the
hypothesis that you know Millennia ago
po potentially it you know gave some
sort of benefit for maybe an infectious
disease or something similar to cystic
fibrosis why you know again this
mutation would persist in our population
if there's not you know you know some
sort of Advantage uh to those carrying
it um but we do see in other you know
other men as well so I think if you know
it's a simple question do you flush if
you flush then maybe alcohol may have
you know more of a a harm than than
someone else and then you know get S of
getting along the lines I think drug use
is something that we should try and you
know we do counsel patients about
because that can also negatively affect
SE quality do you think it's fair to say
that okay moderation is best but if
somebody had the option to either not
drink or drink in moderation that they
should not drink would that be even
better is there any evidence for that I
mean it seems like nowadays we take the
stance that um not smoking at all is
better than smoking a little bit
actually when I was a postto at Stanford
from 200 five yes 2005 to uh end of 2010
um you could still smoke on the Stanford
campus I'm not a smoker but there was
this collection of I have to be careful
what I say here there was a particular
group on campus of postdocs and graduate
students that would um you know that
would colonize this little area outside
the hospital and smoke because that's
where you could smoke that was
eventually um eliminated as a
possibility you can't smoke on Sanford
campus as far as I know but they would
smoke right outside the hospital
actually a lot of the hospital workers
would you know take a cigarette on their
break this is very common yeah and and
this was common all over the country
right this isn't unique to Stanford but
nowadays you just don't see that um
because it's not allowed um and we hear
don't smoke it's terrible for XYZ and
everything every other letter of the
alphabet with alcohol um we tend to hear
that if you're going to drink drink in
moderation um it's not clear exactly
what number that is but is it possible
that zero alcohol is better for sperm
and endocrine Health than any alcohol or
is that not not a fair assumption I mean
I think it's a good question I think you
know the your point about tobacco is an
excellent one because I think any
smoking is bad um but alcohol I think we
don't have that data for yet and so I
think it's it's harder to it's harder
for me to make that recommendation to
patients especially because you know
people do it for different reasons um
and if it's not necessarily going to
help them you know it'll harm them in
social situations or other things um
yeah I usually just I usually give the
the moderation one unless again for the
the very high drinkers definitely talk
about that um you mentioned other drug
use um I'm going to assume that uh
unless prescribed for sort of
postsurgical pain or something like that
that benzodiazapines
heroin opioids of any kind um are just
bad for sperm and testosterone I think
we could probably make that a short
discussion right yeah you know I can't
imagine any of that would be good um for
Reproductive Health yeah that's true I
mean there's again you'd imagine or may
maybe not but there's not a lot of data
on it um it'd be difficult to enroll or
maybe easy to enroll but a lot of those
Studies have not been done um but
there's limited ones of you know people
in rehab uh where they have shown you
know these associations with you know
addicts or users and lower quality so um
yeah that's how we talk to patients what
about cannabis I did an episode of this
podcast about cannabis and I did
highlight some of the medical
applications of cannabis I also
highlighted that very high THC cannabis
um May pred dispose especially young
males to later psychotic episodes there
are more and more data coming out about
that all the time I um got a lot of flak
for for saying that but that's my take
on the data um and um I know a lot of
people use cannabis uh
recreationally um and in a kind of
pseudo therapeutic way I say pseudo
what is the relationship between
cannabis use and testosterone and sperm
production or I should say sperm quality
excuse me yeah so this is also a very
common question um again with this wave
of legalization across the country I
think more and more men and women are
exposed to it um so again there's data
that the more men are exposed to it it
can lead to some harm in terms of sperm
morphology and sperm numbers as well um
you know one of the sort of landmark
studies was about 1,200 men and it found
that men that use cannabis daily had
significantly lower concentration
motility morphology compared to those
that didn't use it um so I think that's
generally how men are counseled but
there's also you know other data that
shows really a null effect and I think
that it's it goes into probably the
composition how men are taking it the
frequency because a lot of that data is
not well teased out in a lot of these
studies um so you know I think I I
sometimes struggle with is with patients
because some of them are taking it for
you know you know some what they
consider legitimate reasons anxiety
sleep pain um and if there's not sort of
very convincing evidence that it's going
to help and they're taking it maybe
lower than the threshold where I know
that there's good data that'll cause
harm you know I guess I'm try to be sort
of honest about where we are but I think
with a lot of things related to sperm I
think our our level of evidence is not
great are there any common
over-the-counter medications that can
negatively impact sperm quality Andor
testosterone things like um non-steroid
anti-inflammatory drugs Tylenol Advil
type stuff um you know ibuprofen
acetamin um things of that sort that I
and others might not be aware of I'm not
I'm not probing for anything in
particular here I just I I know that um
you know a lot of over-the-counter drugs
have effects that we're just simply not
aware of yeah I mean I think we probably
need more data but I think currently we
think all those are safe I'm curious
about the pituitary pituitary gland as
many the listeners of this podcast
already know is a gland that receives
signals from the brain um the gland sits
near the roof of the
mouth um I think that's fair um and
releases critical hormones into the
bloodstream that control the output of
testosterone from the testes as well as
output of hormones from other glands um
I know a number of people will end up
playing sports like football
or rugby or even LaCrosse or even soccer
I've read or data on this you know
they're heading the soccer ball quite a
lot or martial arts or they get a head
injury at some point and
um I certainly hear a lot from people
who played these high contact Sports and
then to their
surprise later they have diminished
testosterone levels I also work with a
number of military groups that talk
about this you know that they leave and
maybe it's from combat related stress
Etc but um they wonder whether or not
there's any traumatic head injury or
maybe pituitary injury related um
impairment to the reproductive axis that
includes brain pituitary and the testes
do you see that um and if somebody
played a contact sport in particular
contact sport where the head was hit or
they were hitting things with their head
often um or if they have a TBI or had a
TBI that um reproductive Health can be
impaired that's F fascinating um I have
I have not I mean I think you know it's
interesting I guess you know what the
pituitary does you've obviously covered
this before but it does go to a lot of
our therapies I mean so you know for
your listeners you know that pituitary
produces two hormones LH lutenizing
hormone and FSH follicle stimulating
hormone which then stimulates the
testicle so the lutenizing hormone
hormone stimulates the Ling cells to
make testosterone and then the follicle
stimulating hormone or FSH stimulates
sperm production so both of those are
very key you know in terms of production
and interestingly when exogenous
testostrone is used you know it shuts
down that axis as you know so we get
less of these gatot tropins this LH FSH
um to stimulate the testicle um and the
other sort of reason that sperm
production is lost with exogenous
testosterone uses is actually the in
testicular testosterone is much higher
than serum levels so you know our serum
levels are you know between 300 and 900
uh nanograms per deciliter on average
but in the testicle are probably tfold
higher at least so when men are given
exogenous testosterone and they're not
producing their own the levels of
testosterone in the testicle which are
necessary for sperm production are much
much lower
um but it's interesting because I think
um I am not aware of sort of how tra
traumatic injuries would would do that
okay um that's good to know I'm curious
about the
nonendocrine
nonchemical so effects on sperm quality
and testosterone levels so here I'm
thinking about uh bunch of news stories
we heard a few years ago about how
Bicycle Seat pressure on the prostate or
maybe it was other other portions of the
um maybe was the uh nerves running to
the penis itself um or surrounding areas
maybe it was pelvic floor related and
somehow you'll tell us I'm sure uh was
impairing sexual function was it
impairing sexual function in any way by
impairing testosterone levels cutting
off blood flow to the testes um and here
perhaps the most important thing to ask
straight off is um is riding a bicycle
bad for male reproductive health and
Sexual Health yeah these are great
questions these again living in the Bay
Area working in the Bay Area uh cycling
is very very popular so these are
questions that I get a lot so I think
you
know I in general like we talked about
before anything that's good for your
heart it's going to be good for
fertility so good diet and exercise
maintain a good body weight and so I
always try and encourage physical
fitness I think that's important but you
know it may be possible that some
particular um activities may put men at
more risk so I think cycling could be
one of them if but it would sort of
depend on exactly why we think that may
be a problem so I guess the theory is
heat if you're in the saddle for a long
time you know these prolonged you know
rides that men take you know on weekends
you know hours um that maybe if there's
too much heat exposure that may be the
mechanism where sperm production would
decline so there have been some studies
say maybe five hours a week would be you
know that may be too much so if you're
above that level the sperm counts shown
to be lower if you're less than that
that may be okay so when I talk to
patients about it I try and just
encourage them to you know stand up in
the saddle to try and again sort of air
things out to try and dissipate heat if
if that's the mechan ISM we're going to
think regarding sexual
dysfunction um that is thought to be
pressure as you're alluding to so you
know the way that the saddle is
configured ideally all the pressure is
put on our iscal tuberosities or our sit
bones that's what I'm sitting on now but
on the saddle you know there's obviously
kind of the rigid nose and if there's
too much pressure on that that actually
squeezes between the iscal tuberosities
where you know the main blood flow to
the penis goes and the main nerve Supply
is too and so if there's compression on
this you get this sort of lack of blood
flow or esea and you can get a
neuropraxia as well if you crush these
nerves and so that over time can lead to
problems so you know some patients will
say that you know after I cycle you know
things are numb down there for 30
minutes um or a day or I don't get
erections for that sort of same amount
of time or sometimes you know men just
sort of you know ride through it um and
you know hopefully things come back in a
day or two so that's that could be the
mechanism and there are some Saddles
that you know hopefully will be a little
safer and you know I think that this
sort of first was noted probably around
the 2000 or so and there is a big
redesign in terms of saddles to try and
make them a little bit more you know
anatomically correct to try and minimize
some of this and there's you know cycle
fit that can be done or saddle fit
rather that can be done at some of the
cycling shops to try and you know look
at your body position look at your size
and try and find a saddle that's safer
um you know not this doesn't happen to
everybody I would say maybe if if you
were to um serve a cyclist maybe 20 to
30% of men and women tend to be
susceptible to this so I think if you
are having discomfort in when you cycle
whether it be pain numbness or you
notice dysfunction I think certainly you
should you know think about changing
saddles or think about changing writing
style um there's other strategies are
sometimes used but you know it's
absolutely something that that everybody
should be aware of I me to ask this
earlier but I seem to recall a study
that Drew a a correlation between um
amount of walking and maybe it was sperm
quality but I think it was testosterone
levels maybe some other metrics of um
male sexual health forgive me I'm not
recalling the details now um is there
any evidence that walking more standing
more maybe even using a standing desk uh
is beneficial for um you know pelvic
floor Health blood flow um prostate
health it who knows could be any and all
of those things in some way that is
beneficial for sperm quality
testosterone level and or overall male
sexual health yeah I think you know one
of the ways that we can characterize
activity is Step count right I think I
know I have a a watch that tells me that
it's something that I look at every day
and kind of strive for it and it turns
out that the more active you are uh it's
been shown sort of looking at you know
large National Data pools across
different age ranges that it is
associated with testosterone levels so
being more active I think is very
important and that's another thing that
you know everybody can do to try and
improve sort of testicular function
broadly but testosterone specifically
and do you know whether or not that can
be separated out from the relationship
between being more active and less obese
I mean is this something that's
independent of of obesity in other words
can we incentivize people to walk more
um simply on the on the promise of um
improved Sexual Health well I don't know
Sexual Health would be a different one
but we can I think there is a
association between testosterone levels
and step count uh across different BMI
straight up so I think you know whether
you're have the ideal body weight
whether you have a few pounds to lose
perhaps if you walk more you will see
higher levels of testosterone okay and
another question I meant to ask earlier
and then we can um close the hatch on on
exogenous testosterone therapy at least
for the time being maybe we'll come back
to it is um assuming that somebody can
maintain adequate sperm production
through the use of HCG or some other uh
therapy
or perhaps they don't care if they're
still making sperm because they've
already had children or they don't care
to have children maybe they've Bank
sperm in any event assuming that
somebody takes testosterone therapy
because they were prescribed that um
let's say in your clinic let's just use
you and your clinic as an example and
they are happy with the psychological
and physical consequences of that and
they are comfortable with the
trade-offs is there any increase risk of
say prostate cancer or other forms of
cancer and here I'm going to assume that
this person is keeping their um their
lipid levels in check right because you
hear about some hyper lipidemia with
testosterone therapies let's assume that
they're either taking a stattin or
they're not taking a stat and they're
getting enough cardiovascular exercise
that things are in check in terms of LDL
HDL apob and all of that and their
testosterone levels are now high normal
and they're feeling better um and they
don't have to worry about sperm
production because it's they're either
maintaining aing it or it's been banked
or they don't care about that um is
there an increased risk of prostate
cancer my understanding is the answer is
no but what's the real deal does taking
testosterone therapy assuming all other
things are being held in a in check in a
healthy check does it increase the risk
of any kind of cancer yeah I mean this
is a another great question because I
think there's a lot of Miss around
testosterone and that's one of them you
know this the origin is that prostate
cancer is thought to be or is sort of
Androgen mediated you know one of the
Nobel prizes U you know again decades
ago was awarded because it was found
that when we lowered a man's
testosterone the prostate cancer would
regress dramatically so that put that
association between testosterone and
prostate cancer so then the concern
became if we were to you know either
replace testosterone or augment
testosterone give a man testosterone is
that going to alter his risk or increase
his risk um so I think we have pretty
convincing data that that's not the case
you know there's lots of logitudinal
data spanning decades where if man is
given testosterone um it doesn't change
its risk the reason for that in sort of
seeming Contra you know this
contradiction between you know prostate
cancer a therapy where we lower
testosterone where if you give a man
testosterone doesn't change his prostate
cancer risk uh is not certain but
there's this popular model called the
saturation model so that once there's
enough testosterone in the body and it's
tends to be a fairly low level um that
all the sort of the prostate test
testosterone receptors you know you can
kind of think of as have been filled so
if you were to give man more
testosterone doesn't change anything
regarding the prostate cancer prostate
growth any of that so it is it is safe
when we're looking at prostate cancer as
an outcome I'd like to just take a brief
break and thank one of our sponsors
which is element element is an
electrolyte drink that has everything
you need and nothing you don't that
means plenty of salt sodium magnesium
and potassium the so-called electrolytes
and no sugar now salt magnesium and
potassium are critical to the function
of all the cells in your body in
particular to the function of your nerve
cells also called neurons now people of
course have varying levels of
requirements for sodium so people with
hypertension or prehypertension probably
shouldn't increase their sodium however
many people are surprised to find that
by increasing their sodium intake they
are able to function better cognitively
and physically and that's because a lot
of people especially people who are
following low carbohydrate or even
moderate carbohydrate and really clean
diets often times they're excreting a
lot of water and electrolytes along with
and simply by increasing their
electrolyte intake using element they
just feel better and function better I
typically drink element first thing in
the morning when I wake up in order to
hydrate my body and make sure I have
enough electrolytes and while I do any
kind of physical training and certainly
I drink element in my water when I'm in
the sauna and after going in the sauna
because that causes quite a lot of
sweating if you'd like to try element
you can go to drink element that's
lm.com huberman to claim a free element
sample pack with your purchase again
that's drink element lnt.com
huberman getting back to prostate health
and um neural inovation of the penis and
and blood flow to the penis you
mentioned the bike seat related issues
are there other things that men should
do in order to maintain prostate health
Stave off prostate diseases and to
maintain healthy blood flow and neural
inovation of the penis for obvious
reasons and we'll get um into the
specifics of those reasons in in our
later discussion yeah I mean I think
that you know I always kind of think of
the penis as a use it or lose it organ
so that doesn't mean necessarily you
have to have sex but you know normally
we get erections every night so that
should be maintained and if there's any
reason to sort of suspect that that may
not be going on um usually in my
practice that would be from you know
some pelvic surgical intervention or
something like that sometimes we can
intervene to try and maintain that
you're talking about spontaneous
erections during sleep right so um and
uh short of assigning uh one's partner
to uh to check um frequency and tence
what is the uh way that men would know
that that's happening are you talking
about waking up with an erection is that
a requisite for knowing that nocturnal
erections are occurring well yeah I
think you yeah you kind of caught me I
think that's a good question so I think
a lot of times you won't know but I
think if you have sort of normal
response you know when either by
yourself with a partner I think that
generally means um that you are going to
get normal erection so I think I guess
when I say use it or lose it it doesn't
mean necessarily the man has to
stimulate himself or kind of um make
sure that he does have you know adequate
function because usually most of that
normal function just occurs you know
with his nocturnal penal tessin which we
all get you know I think sometimes men
do notice when they wake up at night
sometimes in the morning you wake up
with an erection men notice that but the
absence of that doesn't mean it's not
happening it likely is just you know
most people sleep through it which is
normal otherwise men would never get any
sleep because it happens many many times
a night um so I think you know again if
you're not having normal function I
think that's something you should
probably see you know a physician about
and then same for like urinary function
I think if it bothers you if there's you
know if you're waking up at night if you
have to go to the bathroom often if your
stream is getting weaker those are all
sort of complaints that we hear about
what is often um my understanding is
that it's normal to wake up perhaps once
during the night to urinate um and this
is of course assuming and again forgive
me for all the caveats but I've done
this long enough that you know if I
don't get really granular about some of
this then well what if I drank you know
32 ounces of fluid right before sleep
and I'm urinating three times per night
well we're assuming that people are
tapering their liquid intake as they
approach bedtime um and that waking up
once maybe twice but once in the middle
of the night to urinate is normal for
somebody let's say age I don't know 18
to 40 and maybe from 40 to uh 100 um
that number might be in the uh one to
two times per night is that about right
yeah I mean I think once a night yeah is
normal for most men and then I think you
know if things start to bother you I
think you could certainly see somebody
but it's hard to get better than once or
twice a night yeah for most men um my
understanding is that there's a pretty
good relationship between the um
nocturnal erection and the amount of REM
sleep rapid eye movement sleep that one
is getting that this tends to be more
frequent toward morning as the
proportion of rapid eye movement sleep
increases I don't know if that's true or
not but I found a couple of studies that
at least point in that direction no pun
intended uh so that raises a a bigger
issue that we haven't talked about yet
which is getting adequate amounts of
quality sleep each night and um I think
for most people that's s to n hours
ideally um which means getting
sufficient slow wave deep sleep as well
as rapid eye movement sleep but nowadays
A lot of people including young people
who are are not working excessive hours
are um getting you know four five six
hours of sleep per night is there a
direct relationship between getting less
than sufficient amounts of sleep and
sperm quality testosterone levels and um
Sexual Health yeah I mean I think
certainly there's reasonable data for
seman quality and there tends to be um
you know what we call like in science
sort of a u-shape relationship so that
it's not sort of linear so you get more
sleep things are better it there's sort
of there this concept of too much sleep
and not enough sleep so the ideal I
think as you pointed out is 7 to n hours
and for men that are not getting that
seam in quality tends to be lower and
then for men getting too much um we also
see a decline and you know why that is
is again not certain these again if
you're able to get that much sleep maybe
there's other things as well that we
should look at but um so I think kind of
getting in that ideal sleep amount is
best for seam in quality and probably
for broad ttic function as well you keep
bringing up seam and quality um in a way
that makes me wonder whether or not is
seamen quality a proxy for overall
vitality and health or is testosterone
level appr proxy for overall vitality
and health um it sounds like seamen
quality is the the metric that you keep
coming back to in a way that um I have
to assume reflects your you know your
clinical experience and the the the many
um papers that you've authored in this
area um I think for people that hear
Seaman quity and who are not interested
in conceiving children now or who are
which of course could include people
who've already had children or who don't
want children um seaming Quality sounds
like something that relates to fertility
but is seam in quality something that is
a good goal for those who are interested
in overall male vitality and health is
it is it one of the better metrics of
overall male vitality and health well I
think you know
it's I think it's an excellent marker
for overall health I think there are
studies that support it can be a measure
of how healthy you are you know if you
look at men with more health problems
they can have lower seen quality but
also if you look at semen quality just
by itself and then you look into the
future how these men tend to do if they
have higher semen quality um they tend
to live longer need to go to the doctor
less lower rates of cancer so I think
there's a lot of different ways that
seon quality may be a good barometer of
Health um you know it's you know why
that link exists I think is not is not
known but there's lots of theories so
one is that you know probably about 10%
of the male genome is devoted to
reproduction um and so it makes sense
given that we only have about you know
24,000 genes in the body that there's a
lot of um you know overlap so one gene
that plays a role in reproduction may
play a role in the cardiovascular system
or the neurological system and so if we
get the first you know sort of sign that
reproduction is not perfect there may be
some other health consequences down the
line um another sort of hypothesis is
that again sort of going along this line
that reproduction is one of the first
things that we see is that um you know
gestation is sort of very critical to
our you know existence right and
perturbations to that system have
prolonged um you know effects soort of
the so-called sort of Developmental
origin of adult disease or the Barker
hypothesis um and so we know that you
know pretty much sure children have
higher risk of cardiovascular disease or
been studies to show that but we also
know that you know these gestational
effects can also uh play out on
reproductive function too so that also
may be kind of a link you know sort of
early seating of reproductive function
and then that's maybe the first marker
that we're going to have for other
health effects later on um there also
just sort of sort of inherent um sort of
similarities between um reproduction and
some other sort of social effects so you
know know kind of one sort of
confounding Factor when we're looking at
some of these studies I talked about
looking at mortality for example and sem
quality is that you know there's sort of
factors that necessarily involve
reproduction so your children and having
a partner and having a partner prolongs
life um having kids prolong life even
though it feels like kids are killing
you if you look at studies men with kids
tend to live longer um so you know
that's another possible explanation but
I think you know really sort of this
health
um you know link between fertility I
think is sort of a powerful one so I do
think it should be a barometer I think
that you know it should be sort of when
I've given lectures on this I call it
the six Vital sign I think it's
something that we should probably check
because if there is you know sort of
lower levels that may tell us about
something else going on you know when
when men come in for infertility
evaluations a lot of times we do
diagnose you know these new medical
problems sometimes we diagnose cancer
you know sort of alluding to some of the
questions you've as F diabetes and some
other you know very significant genetic
conditions as well and you know the
first way that we would identify it is
reproductive failure because their sperm
counts are low um and other things so it
is something I think that it's sort of
it's very important I think for people
to realize um and it would be great I
think you know another um I think
advantage to like the Centers for
Disease Control for example to to start
tracking it would it be a good idea for
um males in their 20s and 30s to get
sperm analysis to have a baseline I
confess I'm 47 now um one thing I wish I
had done in my 20s was to get my uh
blood hormone profiles and lipid
profiles done when I was in my teens and
20s because I'd have something to
compare to um I started doing that in my
mid-30s and I'm so glad I did because I
can now compare to my mid-30 levels I
started including um sperm analysis
about eight years ago um with the
intention of freezing sperm and did that
um because I was also reading at that
time time about the increased risk of
autism um in offspring of males older
than 40 something that I really would
like your take on but um it seems like
it's inexpensive enough to do a sperm
analysis um I think now they people can
get it done at home they have mail mail
kits although I don't understand how the
motility could be maintained if you're
mailing your sperm back um at room
temperature or you know it's heading
through the post office now everyone's
imagining all these sperm traveling
through the the Postal Service out
they're out there folks um yeah what
what are your thoughts should um should
people invest the I think it was a
couple hundred dollars to get a a sperm
analysis more um costly to get the DNA
fragmentation than you get up into the
low thousands um but if people have the
disposable income is it a good idea for
them to do I mean I think it's a
worthwhile test I think more information
is always good um you know I think sort
of one of the same reasons that um you
know you're talking about checking like
lipid levels or we tell you know men and
women to get blood pressure checked I
think you know getting that sort of
early Health indicator I think can be
important I think you know going back to
not knowing exactly why semen quality is
telling us about health what the exact
link may be you know means that if
somebody is coming in with a low sperm
count or completely absent sperm count
it's hard to know exactly how to counsel
that that person other than the maybe RI
reproductive difficulties um but I think
just as sort of a marker for
Reproductive potential I I think it's
useful and like you said I think it's
become a lot easier one of the sort of
Innovations in the space um and you know
somebody that you know is in the
reproductive world I think it's just
really great to see sort of this influx
in capital and new companies coming in
they're trying to just decrease the
barrier to you know getting a cement
test it used to be you have to go to a
lab schedule an appointment sometimes
they would send you to a bathroom which
can be uncomfortable you know because
people are doing you know you know what
people do in a bathroom just next to
your way trying to collect oh they would
send them into a in a common space
bathroom Comm space bathroom they would
even give them the quiet room with the
with the red light which is uh right
what I hear they do now yeah some of
them do have videos so there are some
higher level oh I didn't even mean
videos I just I I think that um okay yes
I've done this I'll just I mean I'm
trying to normalize things related to
all aspects of mental health physical
health um so um yeah I I decided to
freeze sperm and basically they sent me
to a room I went to a university based
Clinic it actually wasn't Stanford but
different University and um uh yeah they
put the cup through the window they give
you the cup they um they close the door
and they tell you that as long as that
red light is on over the door no one's
going to walk in and then they leave and
I think the the Assumption now is that
uh you figure it out one way or another
um how to provide the sample and then
you put the sample back through the the
thing and then one thing these clinics
really need to work out is that anytime
you're walking out you see the people
processing your sample as you walk out
so there's all this um this figing of of
uh you know anonymity but really it
isn't there you know because they're
like see you later and you're like great
you you know they they rarely ask you
questions on the way out but it's a
pretty simple process overall and um and
I must say that the the data are
informative you get the you know you get
the volume number motile forwardly
motile I did opt for the DNA
fragmentation um data um and I I just
love data so I think it's really
interesting but again um and maybe this
is a good time to flag this what this
set of findings I believe that there
seems to be a small but statistically
significant increase in the number of
autistic births due to pregnancies where
the male was over 40 at the time of um
of conception um so I figured you know
why not freeze some sperm and it's
relatively inexpensive yeah yeah so I
think paternal age is also you know
something that's increasing in this
country so over the last 40 years or so
we've seen that the average paternal age
has increased from about 27 and a half
to about 31 um and I should say that
this is all fathers so um birth
certificate data or birth data is
collected a maternal level so you know
when a child is born somebody comes in
to collect data on the birth so they ask
you know all the characteristics of the
mother and they also ask characteristics
of the father you know age education
obviously region of the country the
child was born um so we don't know you
know what number child that was for the
father we know it for the mother they do
ask you know is your first second their
Etc child um so the father unfortunately
we just have data that sort of all
lumped together um but over the last
again 40 years we've seen that increase
interesting over the last 40 years the
youngest father was 11 and the oldest
was 88 11 quite a span yeah
88 goodness unrelated I I don't know I
assume I assume goodness it's anonymized
data but ium 11 uh I have to ask this
sorry to uh take us on a slight tangent
but what is the average age of of
puberty in males in the United States um
now yeah so asking about I guess sort of
Sparky when like sperm production begins
so um yeah there are a lot of markers of
of puberty secondary sexual characters
of beard growth deepening of voice ET
they happen at different rates and
different people but yeah thank you um
at what point um are um yeah males
undergoing puberty yeah uh at at the
level of of that we're talking about
here yeah so it's yeah there has been
data we're going through puberty a
little bit earlier now than we used to
um but it really varies so you know I
think it's not um you know just like
testosterone ranges between like 300 and
900 that's a wide range for anybody I
think for most individuals you know
puberty is you know probably 12 to kind
of 15 16 in general so I just give sort
of a very wide range when we're going to
say that's okay and you know some of the
data I'm basing it on is um when sperm
production begins in boys and it's
actually you know not that simple to be
be able to figure that out because you
know we don't generally talk to you know
young boys about how to masterbate how
to collect and then check on that but
there's something called first morning
voided urine where we can actually look
at that and there have been some studies
done and they see if there are sort of
you know nocturnal emissions whether
there're sperm in there and so generally
it probably starts around um the
earliest would be kind of 11 12 13 but
usually most is probably a little later
so maybe I'll refine that puberty and
move it a little bit later probably 14
to 16 um is when probably about 70 80%
of boys are going to have produced
started producing sperm my understanding
is that in females puberty is also
shifting earlier perhaps at a more
dramatic rate than appears to be the
case for males well I think there is
some data for males too I think um but
again for your listeners I don't want to
you know have this onslaught of you know
pediatricians seeing kids that haven't
you know and boys haven't gone through
puberty by a certain age so I think it's
still fairly wide
let's get back to age of the father and
issues like
autism um what are the data there um and
this to me is a practical issue because
I think if there's one obvious takeaway
from our discussion today it's that um
males should probably not wait until
they're trying to conceive in order to
assess their reproductive Health at the
level of sperm quality um testosterone
levels perhaps perhaps but at least
sperm quality but um but perhaps men
should also be freezing their sperm if
in fact conceiving children after 40
places their children at far greater
risk for autism I mean my understanding
is that the rates of autism are
somewhere between 1 and 80 you'll hear
as high as one in 50 male birth but I
think it's probably more like one in 60
to 80 is that about right um and that
the age of the father is a risk factor
yeah I think that this gets into sort of
the larger issue of you know how men
sort of perceive fertility so you know
we know that as women age fertility
declines uh but the oldest father ever
is 96 so the biologic potential
certainly persists wait I want to know
how long he lived to see how his child
grow up we he conceived at 96 amaz
supposedly supposedly yeah well I'm
assuming he did not meet his
grandchildren at least not the
grandchild of that child so wow how long
did he live um you know I well so this
this is a man in India it's just right
up famous story but supposedly um he had
a child he was had that child with him
on uh like they're waiting at a bus stop
he fell asleep the child was kidnapped
that led to divorce so yeah Dreadful
sort of a a horrible end but the wife
was also old not not that old but in her
50s so yeah wow um tragic and and
incredible story for separate reasons um
okay I'll get my head around this 996
year-old uh conceiving a child okay
please continue yeah uh so people I
think or men think that the sort of the
um you know their you know F fertile
road is sort of infinite um but I think
that's very much not the case so as
you're alluding to people have looked
into risks for older fathers so you know
about a hundred years ago was first
noticed that dwarfism or condr plasia
was more common in last born children So
eventually that link was made um and
since then other conditions too so
there's like these neuros psychiatric
conditions you're talking about like
autism is certainly one bipolar
schizophrenia people have looked at and
also linked that with older age you know
Less attainment in school you know
failing grades all that has been shown
to be a little bit more common with
older fathers so you know why I think
all these exist there can be sort of
different
explanations um you know one explanation
for the autism Association I'll talk
about um you know some of this more gen
gentic or um of mutational reasons but
one thing that some people say is that
you know it could be sort of a
hereditary trait and so it maybe that
you know men that display some sort of
autistic characteristics you know maybe
they take a little longer to meet a
partner and so it sort of delayed
childbearing so maybe that's that's one
possible explanation but I think you
know there's been a lot of convincing
evidence that there could be you know
real epigenetic changes that occur with
age and mutational changes that occur
with age um I think I read a statistic
and you would know more being a
neuroscientist that 84% of the the genes
in our body are expressed somewhere in
the central nervous system is that
sounds about right yeah I don't want to
stamp my name to that uh um but that
sounds about right so um it's it's
estimated that every year we generate
about two mutations in our um you know
sperm DNA so you can imagine that you
know a 40-year-old is going to have you
know 20 or TR 40 more mutations um than
a 20-year-old so that rate does go up
and if you're just randomly sprinkling
mutations you know in you know a genome
that they're more likely to sort of
manifest in you know maybe neuros
psychiatric conditions um so there are
you know data convincing data that shows
that that does occur now again there's
billions of base pairs in the body so
these random mutations likely most of
them will will not result in anything
but there can be some meaningful ones so
for example Le a condr plasia it's due
to a mutation in fiberblast growth
factor receptor um and what's
interesting is that this condition is
not that rare right based on sort of
these rare mutations you'd expect this
would you know occur maybe about one in
100 million but it turns out these these
conditions occur in about one in I think
30 to 50,000 or so so there's sort of
the discrepancy based on sort of
mutational rate that we expect based on
age and the rate that we actually see so
the explanation for this is something
called selfish spermatogonial selection
so what this suggests is that some of
these mutations that occur randomly
occur in proliferation Pathways and so
it gives the sperm that contain these
sort of advantages over their you know
brothers and sisters that don't have
them for example and so then they out
compete the other sperm and so they're
more likely to lead to a child rather
than sort of a random smattering you can
actually see that some of these
mutations are more common in older men
than younger men if you look you screen
for some of these mutations in you know
some of these Pathways um
again the longer that we're exposed to
life there's just more likely to be you
know different chemical exposures other
exposures and so people have looked at
epigenetic signatures sort of these
signatures that um you know that dictate
which genes are going to be expressed
and which aren't and there are different
patterns between older and younger
fathers and you know why what triggering
those is not known but there are
differences so those could also
potentially explain you know some of
these risks that we see um you know it
used to be that people thought that you
know if you're an older father maybe
there's a lot of advantages you you know
for the kids right because if you're
you're more resourced right I always
tell patients that you know when they
come to see me for like erection
problems or anything I always say
nothing gets better with age right and
that's mostly true although theyve
pointed out that um salary often goes up
with age and wisdom goes up with age so
you would imagine if you're more
resourced maybe the kids are going to
also have an advantage to that but you
know again there's a lot of convincing
data that that's that's probably not the
case um there's even there's one study
that I saw that showed that if you look
at MRIs uh of brains of children just
after birth they're actually a little
smaller for older fathers compared to
younger fathers so um I think there are
some you know sort of talking about kind
of neurocognitive development um some of
those effects and there's also been um
studies looking at cancer risk too so
higher risk of breast cancer prostate
cancer and adult children higher risk of
you know leukemia or CNS Cancers and
children as well so I think the more we
look the more we find out of these
associations with paternal age um so I
think it's some you certainly be aware
of I think you talking about mitigation
strategies I think sort of Education
would be important for you know couples
to try earlier you individuals to try
earlier to conceive you know if we think
it's a mutational reason I think um you
know certainly freezing sperm I think is
a is a good option as
well my understanding is that um
analysis of DNA fragmentation in sperm
didn't does not allow for selection of
the best sperm on the basis of uh DNA
composition um translated to English
what I mean is in order to tell whether
or not this the DNA are mutated in a
sperm you have to kill the sperm
basically so um and since um in a given
pool of sperm so to speak um there will
be forward motile non-motile twitchers
twitching in place dead sperm um some
percentage of dead sperm or immotile
sperm is presumably normal some small
percentage hopefully um and that some
might have some DNA fragmentation some
might not so um is the way to address
this um averages what I'm hearing here
is that if you haven't already had kids
or if you want more kids um that you
might want to know about your sperm
quality I would say you do um and that
if you can afford it you might want to
take a look at DNA fragmentation data um
but having done this um what one
receives is a chart that goes from Red
bad to Green good and then they put the
arrow hopefully in the green zone and
then you say oh good you know I'm in the
green zone I don't have fragmented DNA
in my sperm but really that's an
averaging of all the sperm right it
could be that as you age that some
percentage of those sperm have
fragmented DNA and um if one of those is
the one that successfully um wins the
egg so to speak um fertilizes the egg
then that fragmented DNA containing
sperm is going to propagate that into
your offspring so are there any
technologies that can allow men to um
select or for or improve the DNA of
their sperm not just the motility I me
yeah I wish right that's sort of the
Holy Grail because I think he pointed
out sort of a variant of right the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle is that
we can't if we identify which sperm is
bad we're necessarily going to destroy
it so to tell you know which one is
harboring these mutations um would be
great but I think we're not there yet I
mean one thing that we do do is wash
sperm so we do sort of Select the most
modal sperm we clear out the dead ones
um and I think embas are pretty good at
telling which sperm they think are
better but you again we don't have any
real objective data to try and
understand you know which are harboring
something or other but I think if we
understood more about this link with age
or again other conditions um hopefully
we'll be able to stop some of this pass
through let's get back to the prostate
um this incredible gland tell tell us
about the prostate I I think we hear
about the prostate we hear about
prostate cancer um
people might have heard that it's
involved in the ejaculatory response
it's involved in erections it's involved
in a number of things if you could give
us a you know catalog of things that the
prostate does um I you spent a lot of
time thinking about this gland what are
some of the cooler things that it that
it does that we don't know about um you
know how do we keep it healthy uh and
what are the consequences of not keeping
it healthy yeah so the prostate is a
gland about the size of a walnut it sits
behind the bladder and it's involved in
reproduction it produces some of the
proteins enzymes that are necessary for
you know sperm to be supported and you
know the ejacalate to kind of keep the
the sperm healthy um in the female
reproductive tract so you know it
functions in reproduction and then
basically after reproduction is done it
doesn't really serve any useful function
so then it just becomes a problem
essentially so the urethra which is
where we pee through so it connects the
bladder you know to exits the body um
runs right through the prostate and as
we age the prostate does get bigger
that's sort of a known thing and as the
prostate gets bigger it creates sort of
more resistance in this pipe and so it
makes the bladder have to work harder
and that leads to a lot of the symptoms
you know that we've been talking about
already you know waking up at night weak
stream this need to uh urinate urgently
um sometimes feeling like you're not
emptying all the way so it's sort of a
consequence of the prostate um sort of
being there uh in terms of ways that you
can keep the prostate healthy I think
that there's really nothing that you
know necessarily can do I think that you
know one thing I talk to patients about
when these sort of symptoms start is to
know some of the triggers so um you know
like you mentioned drinking a lot before
you go to bed so if you don't want to
wake up at night that's not a good
practice you know may even want to go
into bed sort of a little dehydrated
just so you can try and last the night
um there are some you know particular
drinks or foods that tend to be more
irritating so like spicy foods acidic
Foods those can sometimes irritate the
lining of the bladder and make you have
to pee a little bit more you know
caffeine is a diuretic uh so it makes us
urinate more and it also um uh can also
irritate the bladder and give you that
sensation alcohol will do the same thing
so I think you know kind of knowing some
of those triggers May kind of saave off
some of the symptoms a little bit but
you know again if you enjoy those vices
and you're willing to tolerate it that's
okay too I'm hearing more and more about
a practice of people taking low dose to
dofil seis um low dose meaning in the
neighborhood of 2.5 to 5 milligrams per
day um not necessarily for erectile
dysfunction but for prostate health and
was um somewhat surprised to learn that
those drugs were actually developed
first for treatment of prostate health
to increase blood flow to the prostate
um is that true and um is there good
reason to um think about taking 2.5 to 5
milligrams of tadalfil per day simply
for maintaining blood flow to the
prostate and thereby maintaining or
improving prostate health I mean
certainly it can do that it can
definitely help with some of these
urinary symptoms that we've been talking
about you know looking at Placebo
control trial sort of our highest level
of evidence does show that you know low
dose of tadalfil these two and a half to
5 milligram these daily dosing um can
help with these urinary symptoms so I
think that not necessarily it's a
preventative measure but for men that
are bothered you know otherwise I think
most men probably wouldn't want to take
a pill every day but certainly if you
have some of these symptoms it can
definitely help with urinary bother and
then the added benefit is you also
alluded to is it can help with the
rectile function as well even at the 2.5
to 5 milligram dosage interesting um
yeah my experience is that there are a
lot of people who would love to take
pills every day um there seems to be a
kind of binary distribution where um and
here I'm just thinking about the malale
that I hear from because I hear from of
course males and females but um I get a
lot of questions about what can I take
what can I take what can I take um and
uh but as you point out there's also a
category of of of men who seem to um not
want to take anything not want to
measure anything not want to take
anything but especially not take
anything and then there's the other
group um and the other group somewhat
surprisingly seemed to be the L the
younger excuse me population um who
maybe grew up in the YouTube era or
maybe in the era where Sexual Health was
discussed more openly than it was
certainly when I was in college I mean
the extent of sexual health discussions
in my high school and I went to a very
good high school where um it only takes
one sperm which as you pointed out is
true for IV F but more is better if
you're trying to conceive naturally um
and um there were discussions about
communication and consent obviously
super important um and then um they just
kind of turned us loose uh to learn from
our friends and other sources I mean
that and family sometimes had the
discussion sometimes didn't um uh
different families different discussions
obviously um so very very little
information nowadays I think there's a
lot more discussion about these things
and so the 20 to 40y old male crowd
seems to be the crowd that are asking
yeah what can I take these are also the
people who are getting on testosterone
therapy early perhaps without the need I
just want to flag that because um I I
think uh if I understand correctly um
you're seeing a lot of testosterone
therapy that perhaps people don't need
is that right well I think it's a mix
some people probably do need it but I
think that you know before starting it
everybody should be aware of all the
risks and you've kind of highlighted
some but testosterone any any medication
right is going to have some risks and so
everybody needs to be aware of what
those are and for testosterone
reproduction is certainly one of them
and if they're not already doing all the
other things getting adequate sleep
limiting their alcohol intakes not
smoking getting exercise Etc seems that
testosterone therapy would not be the
primary entry point like first work out
all the right all the basics I think
that's the big difference I think
nowadays the what should I take question
comes up early when people aren't
necessarily doing all the other things
um that they could do to promote their
health anyway this is observational on
my part um you're the one whose's Clinic
they're showing up uh too um have a
question about
UTI um we hear about UTI urinary tract
infections um in women pretty often um
do men get UTI if they're getting more
than one UTI per year is that abnormal
um should uh men be uh examined for for
um this bladder urethra prostate penile
architecture I know there are ways that
people can come in I was reading about
this prior to this episode that um you
can ingest a Dy and then they can die
image the whole apparatus is that right
that's true without having to cut
anything is right is that worth people
doing or is that only under conditions
where people are experiencing some some
um some vexing issue yeah I think that
some of those tests should only be done
if there's a problem but I think a male
urinary tract infection is rare enough
enough that it should be evaluated so
women have very short urethras but men
have a very long urethra right it has to
go through the entire penile urethra the
prostatic urethra up into the bladder
and so the way a urinary tract infection
would happen you know one way would be
that a bacteria actually gets all the
way you know back and that's just a much
longer Trek um and so if something rare
like that does happen we look for
anatomic causes for that so there can be
different scar tissue in the uretha for
example there can be stones in the
bladder there can be stones in the
kidney sometimes men AR emptying their
bladders all the way so those those men
should be evaluated because there can be
some pathology that we could hopefully
identify
incorrect let's talk about erectile
dysfunction um I put out the call for
questions in anticipation of this
episode and um no surprise um at least
30% of the questions from males were
about erectile dysfunction um or uh
questions about what's normal in terms
of libido level kind of interesting
right you know and we'll deal with the
first question first but um what are the
most common causes erectile dysfunction
are they hormonal in nature I think
that's a a common belief that if people
are experiencing erectile dysfunction
that it's because their testosterone
levels are too low hence all the
interest in um testosterone therapy um
or are there other say blood flow
related pelvic flow related neural um
brain to um
to body neural connections that are
responsible I'm guessing it's all of
these things how do we parse this um and
yeah what tell us about erectile
dysfunction what you most commonly see
what you most commonly do in order to
treat it yeah so you know erectile
dysfunction is you know sort of the
inability to consistently achieve and
maintain an erection and it's fairly
common um you know of all the conditions
I see that's definitely the number one
so you know if you look at men over the
age of 40 over half will have some
trouble with erections under age of 40
is probably about 15 to 20% so this is a
very common condition that we see in
terms of the ideology it can vary a
little bit you know we used to think
that they were primarily psychogenic um
but that was you know years that was
decades ago now we know that most of
them are organic so it's actually a
blood flow issue so the most common
conditions just sort of nationally would
be the same things that cause blood flow
problems anywhere in the body so high
blood pressure diabetes you know
atherosclerosis anything that sort of
can impair blood getting you know to the
end organ um and sometimes you know
there has been data that you know
trouble with erections can actually
predate other more you know serious you
know vascular conditions so the blood
vessels in the penis the penal arteries
are about 1 millimeter you know and the
heart and the Brain they're much larger
so you know it's much easier to olude a
small vessel than a large vessel so
that's why there have been some studies
to support that it's sort of an early
marker for vascular disease um so I
think looking at those risk factors you
know sort of Lifestyle obesity again is
another is a common one um endocrine
disorders actually fairly small it's
probably less than 10% probably around
5% or so um pelvic cancer treatment is
another very common one after you know
treatment for prostate cancer whether it
be radiotherapy or surgical therapy
bladder cancer um sometimes rectal color
rectal cancer that treatment also
anytime that we're you know um involving
some of the nerves and the the vascular
and the pelvis that can also impact uh
erectile function as well what about
hernia hernia that should be separate so
sometimes if there you know I always say
that in medicine you can never say never
um but you know generally if that was
going to manifest as erectile function
would probably be due to maybe some pain
syndroms which can rarely happen during
just the early post-operative period but
the blood supply the nervous Supply is
separate so you said something very
important for people to hear so I'm
going to highlight it um you said that
less than 10% of erectile dysfunction is
due to a hormonal issue um I don't know
how much time you're spending on YouTube
and the internet but um that is going to
be a shocker for a lot of males out
there because so much of the discussion
around testosterone is around libido and
sexual function so um it's key for
people to hear that it's also key for
them to know about this other
90% um when you say blood issue then
what is the common first pass for
treatment and again I and forgive me for
listing this off over and over but we
are assuming here that people have
gotten their body weight down they're
sleeping enough they're not ingesting
excessive alcohol they're not smoking or
vaping they're not smoking cannabis um
or doing the Edibles although maybe we
should talk about Edibles and cannabis
and endocrine effects we'll do that
later um doing all the things right
avoiding doing the wrong things too
often or at least completely so we're
assuming they're doing all that
correctly their testosterone levels are
somewhere in that 300 to 900 nanogram
per deiler range that's typical for the
the so-called reference range uh in at
least in the US I think it goes up to
1,200 or maybe, 1400 in other countries
but um as other countries like to point
out um but it starts at two no I'm just
kidding um but assuming they're doing
everything correctly and it's not a
testosterone issue then if it's a blood
flow issue um meaning they haven't had
treatment for some pelvic
cancer what is the first line of
treatment yeah so assuming that
lifestyle you know and all that has been
optimized medical treatment has been
optimized there's a lot that we can do I
always tell men as long as you have a
penis we can always make it hard so
there's there's a tremendous amount I'm
sure you're the most um popular doctor
in your field that yeah that usually
does kind of ease everybody um so
usually we start with oral therapy so
phosph phosph estras inhibitor therapy
so that would be like selenop or Viagra
tadalfil Calis avenil Stendra venil
litra and would you be willing to talk
about some of the specifics there are
you um is the typical thing to put
people on this 2.5 to 5 milligrams per
day low dose or to um give the higher
doses that are more commonly used uh for
rectile dysfunction per se I think it
depends we know why we're putting them
on and how much sex they have too you
know on average people probably have sex
you know partner sex maybe once a week
on average you know when we're looking
at men in their kind of 30s and Beyond
you know sometimes it can be a few more
times a week than that but you know if
they're having sex every day or very
often then sometimes a daily dose can be
useful but generally most men are on
just on demand because they're going to
fall into that you know maybe about you
know a few times a month category so
that's usually where we start and you
know there is sort of a titration that
can be done you can go slightly you know
higher doses or lower doses so usually
we start in the middle to the higher
doses um
and you know we talk about some of the
side effects they may have but those
probably help 60 to 70% of men um and
they work well you know in terms of
another common question is how do we
decide which one we're going to start
sometimes insurance will tell us which
one we're going to do um that's a common
one you know all these medications tend
to be somewhat similar one difference
tends to be the time of onset you know
how quickly they reach Peak levels in
the body and then also how quickly
they're cleared from the body so
tadalfil is somewhat different and then
it lasts longer the half full life is
about 20 hours or so so it's sort of
marketed as a weekend pill so some
people like the idea of that you know
taking a pill on Friday so having some
left on Saturday um but for others you
know we start with with one of the other
ones the fact that these drugs like to
Dil uh also called Calis right is Calis
the brand name right okay and um Viagra
is that a brand name right stands for um
what is the generic name oh sofil s okay
um so so because they are effective in
such a large percentage of cases what
does that say about the vascular system
of all these males that are um having
erectile dysfunction but then it's
getting resolved by these drug
treatments is that in other words
somebody comes into your clinic they're
having this issue you prescribe um one
of these drugs they come back and say
everything's working great or maybe they
don't come back they just you know send
an email say everything's great um but
do you need to have a discussion with
that person about their over overall
vascular health because a few minutes
ago you told us that the fact that they
weren't getting erections due to what
now appears to be a vascular issue um
can be resolved for the penile tissue
but um is it going to solve their other
vascular issues or should those people
be on the lookout for cerebrovascular
cardiovascular disease that can
potentially cause things at least as bad
as erectile dysfunction and may be worse
yeah absolutely well I think they should
be screened so you know sometimes I'm
diagnosing in the first doctor that
they're seeing in a long long time um
but otherwise I do encourage them to see
a primary care doctor to be screened for
you know blood pressure lipid levels you
know fasting U blood glucose all those
things again sort of for early markers
of some of these sometimes they're
identified sometimes not but I think
it's you know I think we kind of talked
about sort of the ideal patient that's
perfect body weight nothing else is
going on but that's as you know a very
rare entity so usually there's something
that can be done to be optimized and I
don't I try not to be alarmist about
this but I do want to you know encourage
men to sort of take ownership of the
health cu sometimes can improve um you
know some of these conditions but again
we have terrific medications for for men
in whom we cannot what are the common
side effects of these drugs so they're
baso dilator they open up blood vessels
so we get some offt Target effects so
headache facial flushing back eggs leg
cramps indigestion nasal congestion
those would be the most common before
the last Super Bowl there was some press
about the fact that a lot of the players
were taking these drugs at low dosages
before the game presumably to increase
blood flow of their muscles and brain is
that is that what the rationale was I
think so yeah you know another is we
talked about sort of how cycling may
lead to erectile problems or sexual
problems there has been some data
looking at taking like biago or one of
these medications the AL to alil before
a ride again to try and increase
circulation to decrease the chance of
any of the negative effects of prolonged
saddle pressure so it sounds like just
increasing blood flow and lowering blood
pressure slightly is just a good thing
all around yeah I think there's
certainly a benefit yeah because these
medications were originally I think as
you're alluding to were developed as a
blood pressure treatment and this was
sort of an amazing of Target effect that
has turned into a billion doll
industry so you mentioned about 10% or
less of erectile dysfunction is due to
endocrine issues was it 60 to 70% can be
resolved with um with these blood flow
influencers I know it's a terribly non
uh non-clinical non-scientific way
describe the Viagra Calis to delil um
Etc um what about the remaining
percentage and are there other
treatments that um you you prescribed or
or given um in which cases do you need
to uh resort to um I guess more invasive
approaches yeah so another therapy we
have is urethal suppository so you can
actually put a medication in the tip of
the penis it's then absorbed by the rest
of the penis Al inject suppository
suppository or a gel or a jelly yeah um
so it's also a basad sort of the concept
is very similar um sometimes that you
know is is okay for men and they
tolerate it it's uh safe for partners as
well um it can tingle a little bit so we
definitely let men know because um one
of the main medications does cause like
a little bit of a a burn as well why
would somebody do this as opposed to
taking the pill form of the drugs we
were just talking about mostly efficacy
would be a big one um and so this this
this can sometimes help where others
cannot so that's one uh penile
injections are another common therapy so
the efficacy of penile injections are
probably 80 to 90% uh again we're
injecting basa dilators into the penis
so the idea just opens up blood vessels
easier to get and to keep erections you
can imagine there's a huge psychological
barrier to putting an needle in your
penis is this something that the
patients are doing for themselves at
home or that you're doing is it long
lasting is that something you do at the
clinic and then they come back every few
weeks or so no yeah this is an ond
demand treatment so we we teach them how
to do it the first time I do it with us
in clinic ideally we try and get an
erection that lasts probably 20 to 30
minutes so we usually start at a low
dose and then they just increase at home
until they get you know an erection that
lasts for that amount of time is it
injected subcutaneous or actually into
the
um goodness the meteor tissue of of the
penis that's right into the erectile
bodies directly yeah and they you only
have to inject one side they do
communicate with each
other most men say it's fine it's a
small it's a very small gauge needle
about as big as you know a few strains
of here like I have an appointment over
in Opthalmology and I've seen injections
into the human eyeball and it is
incredible how fast and how painless
that procedure is when it's done by the
right person nobody should try that at
home on their own but when it's done by
a skilled opthalmologist it's just
striking you know you hear you think
about needle in the eye you know what's
worse it's like the childhood rhyme
right stick a needle in my eye like
can't think of anything worse but um
maybe you know an injection in the penis
sounds almost as bad but you're telling
me that if patients are prescribed this
that they can do this with with limited
if any discomfort well it does have a
high dropout rate surprise surprise um
yeah I think no one's excited about it
you know it's I guess the mood can
sometimes be affected but a lot of
couples are very comfortable with it
again it's very efficacious the part the
man can do it his partner can do it um
so it does work
well and I I guess here we're sort of
ascending the the list of um
invasiveness right um what what is at
the the sort of top tier of invasiv
for for retile dysfunction so then we go
into penile implants so there's actually
a surgical procedure we can do to put a
device inside the penis that can help
men be hard when they want to and that
comes in sort of two main forms there's
either non-inflatable or inflatable so
the non-inflatable sort of a bendable um
it's you know has sort of a metal core
and so when men don't want to have sex
they bend it down when they're ready for
sex they can kind of bend it up it's
really just they on demand yes H yeah
interesting yeah so it's simple to use
um sort of the more I guess kind of um
sort of natural form would be the
inflatable so when you're not using it
it's deflated and then when you're ready
to use it it's inflated and you inflate
it with basically a pump that's in the
scrotum so all this is sort of
surgically implanted inside a man all
under the skin you know unless you know
what you're looking for it'd be very
difficult to tell if a man has it or
doesn't have it but when he's ready he
pumps it up and it moves fluid from a
reservoir some you which usually is also
it's also surgically implanted into the
penis to get a rigid
erection what is the relationship
between psychological arousal and
erection as it relates to these
Technologies I mean the way you're
describing it sounds purely mechanical
right um we're talking about nocturnal
erections which I suppose people could
be having erotic dreams but I don't
think that's a a prerequisite for
nocturnal erections at all right so um
is the idea that if adequate blood flow
is achieved then any signal from the
brain can initi create a Cascade of
blood flow that creates the erection or
is it the case with some of these
treatments that um sounds like blood
flow is almost um autonomous right well
I think a lot of these um yeah the blood
flow is not adequate and that's why
we're having to you know sort of go
beyond but generally as you point out
there's different stimulation whether it
be you know visual tactile or factory um
that sort of starts that Cascade that
releases neurotransmitters in the penis
that leads to this phase of dilation you
know natur and men get erections a few
years ago I was reading about um
vasopress inhalence you know there was a
bunch of stuff hitting the market um by
the way I don't suggest that people um
get experimental with this stuff you
know as a neuroscientist who also um
knows the thing about neuropeptides and
neuro hormones that can impact the
hypothalamus you know I just I I just
cover my eyes and kind of um cringe when
I think about people inhaling
vasopressin thinking oh yeah you know
there's a study that vasopressin
increases sexual desire or something
like that um but nowadays I'm reading a
lot more about a really interesting
peptide um treatment which I think is a
FDA approved prescription drug which is
um relates to uh a um melanocyte
stimulating hormone that comes out of
the medial pituitary um that is used to
increase sexual desire it's prescribed
for women um but men are starting to
take it um and it seems to have at least
from what you read on the internet um a
pretty profound impact on libbido and on
erectile frequency and persistence um is
this something that you know it's you're
using in your clinic um uh yeah what
about these peptides that people are
inhaling and injecting and some of them
are taken in oral form but most often I
think it's nasal inhalent or um uh or
it's uh a subcutaneous
injection yeah so um those are not ones
that that we use in clinic but I think
you know looking at sort of just sexual
dysfunction broadly there are a lot of
things that you know we do try and help
um and one of the things sort of that I
kind of relates to that that is it's
been a proposed treatment for it is this
concept of delayed orgasm or delayed
ejaculation so I think everybody's
familiar with premature ejaculation
right where men ejaculate too quickly um
but on the other end of the spectrum
there's men that takes you know a long
time to ejaculate and you know what that
is is sort of defined differently but
generally most people would say like
sort of two standard deviations above
average so on average probably around 5
minutes or so two standard deviations
would be kind of 20 to 25 minutes so for
men that take that long to ejaculate
that would be considered delayed or
sometimes they don't ejaculate every
time that they you know have relations
so for those I think there is a need for
treatment because there's no FDA proov
therapy for that um and so that's why I
think you know providers are trying some
of these other you know more
experimental things um there's some that
we use just not that one in particular
um there's also some device that have
been trial as well but it's it's a
challenge because you know I certainly
you really feel for these men um it's
one of the pleasures in life um and some
of them are never able to have sex or
only or sorry never able to orgasm and
some are only able to do it very rarely
so we do want to offer them
benefit what about pelvic floor Health
more generally um the topic of pelvic
floor health is something that comes up
more often around female reproductive
Health in urology um you hear about keel
Kagel kull I don't know I guess we'll
have to ask him because it turns out
Keel Kagel was a person um who named the
exercise after himself um whether or not
he did them or not I do not know but um
my understanding is that Kagel are a
pelvic floor strengthening exercise um
and my understanding is that some people
experience urinary or sexual dysfunction
because of a overly relaxed AKA weak
pelvic floor but that some people have
the exact same problems because of a
hypercontracted AKA overly tense tight
strong pelvic floor meaning don't run
out and start doing kull just because
you heard about them they're not good
for everybody they might be bad for
certain people but what about pelvic
floor health I mean should men be paying
attention to pelvic floor Health should
men be doing pelvic floor exercises I
mean I think it's really key that you
say that because you know not everything
you hear about is good and I think it's
not good for the right person so so
there are certainly men that I see that
have very you know just a lot of tension
a lot of anxiety sometimes these men you
know urinate every hour I mean there's
other things and you can just tell
they're just sort of very wound up and I
think for that man you know one of the
issues you kind of allude to is he
probably needs to relax more so you know
pelvic floor Physical Therapy can still
benefit you because there are some just
different feedback exercises that could
be done to help with relaxation so you
know any eurologist office there's
usually a list a lot of different
providers around the region that can
help with some of these um Keele
exercises though can be useful you know
for example for um like prostate cancer
Rehabilitation some of these men where
we're trying to kind of rebuild some of
the strength or maintain or improve
continence in these men we do want to
strengthen some of these muscles so that
they can sort of recreate or replace
what was lost when the prostate was
removed so I think for the right man
they can be useful but yeah it could be
a dangerous tool in the wrong hands and
you mentioned that if people want to
learn more about pelvic floor therapy um
they can contact their local urologist
and find a good pelvic floor good male
pelvic floor specialist do they tend to
specialize male female they're usually
uh pretty much gender or sex agnostic so
they usually are able to help all and um
forgive me for uh asking for an Abridged
Anatomy lesson here but um could you
describe the pelvic floor muscles and
how they relate to the bladder prostate
urethras anatomy that you talked about
before because I have the picture of the
bladder urethra prostate penis in my
brain um I know um by uh life experience
where the testes and scrotom are
relative to all of that but now I'm
trying to figure out um how like so the
pelvic floor a bunch of muscles that
that are attached to the pelvis but how
do they interact with those uh with
those organs yeah good question so they
sit beneath you know the sort of in the
perineum so the area between the scrotum
and the anus and Beyond too so they
basically support all the structures
there they support you know the base of
the penis the prostate the bladder the
rectum uh and you know they're they kind
of keep M you know adequate tension to
keep all those structures up they relax
when you know different functions are
necessary they're very important for
ejaculation um you know some people
think that they kind of trigger some of
the orgasmic response as well um you
know sometimes men will have you know
pain in that area in the perinal area
can transmit to other parts of the body
like the scrotum you know one of the one
cause of scrotal pain and there can be
many can sometimes be pelvic floor
dysfunction so I think you know again P
pelvic floor therapy can be useful for
sort of a constellation of symptoms
against some urinary symptoms as well so
I think for some patients it can be
helpful but um you know again there if
if you get things too tense um that can
sometimes be harmful so presumably these
pelvic floor therapists also help people
achieve a more relaxed pelvic floor if
that's what they need exactly got it
going to some of the questions that um
came back to me when I solicited for
questions in anticipation of this
episode um several not a few um let's
say a couple dozen people asked about
split urine stream is that a signature
of prostate overgrowth is that a a
urethal issue is it perfectly normal um
I'm assuming here they mean a split
stream of urine that doesn't unify at
any point they're talking about a
consistently split urine stream and for
those of you that don't know what I'm
talking about we're talking about a
urine stream that's actually two urine
streams and we're assuming one urethral
opening because I hit the literature on
this and um there is a case of of
failure to fully fuse the urethral duct
during development where people
some I'm assuming small fraction of
males have a ureth opening on the base
of the penis and at the tip of the penis
let's rule that out as a a possibility
for now um but now that it's on the
table what percentage of males have that
uh twoe reill openings so well
hypospadius what you're describing where
the the actual meatus is not at the tip
but it's kind of along the proximal
urethra or you know even further down
sometimes in the scrotum probably about
1% of bursts um and usually it's
recognized at Birth and oftentimes it's
surgically corrected because it's better
to repair it early rather than later
okay so ruling that out um what is the
cause of split urine stream and is it um
a signature of a larger
you know one of the reasons that we you
know urin a sort of um from an
evolutionary standpoint right is to you
know basically deposit in sort of a
convenient time our waste and we don't
want to get it everywhere because we
don't want to sort of label ourselves um
with smell of urine because that'll be
easier for predators to to be able to
identify so just similar to today we'd
like everything to get in the toilet
without creating a mess so anytime
there's turbulent flow um it it
certainly could signal an issue so it
could be like your re issues are
pointing out a prostatic issue
inadequate speed you know of getting the
urine out the meatus so you definitely
should see you know a physici to get
evaluated because there's likely some
issue that could be
improved the most popular question I
received from males however was about
perhaps no
surprise penis
length you're an expert in this actually
um not just because you're a urologist
male reproductive health expert but um
you published a study recently on the
changing Trends in penile length um tell
us about that study I have so many
questions about um the methodology
because um I have to assume this didn't
involve self-report right those were
excluded yeah yeah so um lying was
excluded um being fous here but um yeah
how was this study done I mean pretty
incredible stud study um
and the results are I don't know if
they're surprising or not I I first I
thought oh this is surprising but the
results were only surprising in light of
what you were talking about earlier
about sperm and testosterone levels I
think um I'll let you describe the study
now rather than than giving people the
punch line here yeah so I mean the
origin was that we were looking at we
wanted to know average lengths for
another project that we were doing and
you know going down the rabbit hole this
has been reported for decades you know
there's different reasons that people
have reported P length you know
sometimes they do it uh just on
volunteers again to sort of get the
average lengths of different populations
sometimes it's done pre and pr-
surgically to try and understand what
changes would occur um so we just sort
of called the literature found data on
55,000 men all over the world um and
wanted to see if there was a you know
sort of a Time pattern with that and
similar to your hypothesis we assume
based on all the other data that we
would likely see a decline you know
whether it be you know chemical
environmental exposure but if nothing
else if we're getting bigger you know
the functional penal length should
decline because you know the super pubic
fat pad will get a little bit bigger and
so we'll kind of lose penal length with
that and so much to our surprise the
super pric F pad excuse me um being the
pad of fat directly over the penis right
right and so you know if that gets
bigger that'll necessarily compromise
penile length but you know as you
alluded to we found is actually the
opposite that um the penises were
getting getting longer with time so how
it's measured measured differently so
one of our inclusion criteria was that
all the studies had have measured sort
of in an office sort of in a clinical
setting so whether it be a you know a
clinician or whether it be a researcher
that actually did it so there's
different ways you can measure a penis
you can just do a stretch length so you
kind of stretch it up as much as you can
and then use sort of a ruler to measure
how long it is again from as deep as you
can get you know the pubic bone ideally
up to the tip of the the glands or the
okay guys so here's what he's describing
he's talking about measuring from the
top not from the bottom
Believe It or Not people ask questions
about this um my daughter made that joke
actually oh yeah yeah yeah uh measuring
from the top not from the bottom no
cheating um you're talking about
stretching the penis while it's flaccid
presumably and then measuring from
essentially contact with the a location
that's contact with the pubic bone to
the the tip right okay so that that
length was recorded in 50,000 men mhm
wow yeah so that was one and then we
also looked at a w length and so there's
different ways that an erection can be
achieved sort of in a clinical setting
so one is you can ask a man to stimulate
himself and then measure so that was
some of the studies and then the other
method as we've alluded to earlier is
you can inject a man with a medicine to
give him an erection and then measure it
and did 50,000 men participate in that
aspect of the study it was less no that
was I think that was about probably 10
to 15, men I have to wondering whether
or not it's easy or difficult for people
to recruit subjects for these studies I
don't know I could see it going in both
ways yeah some of the studies actually
had a tremendous number had about um
like 15,000 men some individual studies
contributed that and actually
interestingly after we published it
there were some men that volunteered uh
for the next study to be measured I'm
sure you'll hear from some of them after
this episode um what was the major
finding so the major finding we wanted
to do is just give normative data we
found that it varied around the world So
based on different regions um the
average lengths you know varied a little
bit but generally on average um erect
penis is probably between about 5 to 6
Ines somewhere in that neighborhood so
that was kind of the take-home we want
that was the average the average for
wlink did you publish the full
distributions uh we didn't I think we
were we're we're our plan was actually
to make a follow- on study so we could
show everybody you know I guess probably
they were interested where they kind of
fell on the graph but it was fairly you
know it was normally distributed yeah I
would think that um despite the um you
know the wide availability of
pornography that um um that the
distributions like the Scatter Plots of
all the data uh would be interesting to
men um for the same reason that the
testosterone by function of age data
published as a scatter plot in that
textbook I referred to earlier right
were interesting because um the scatter
plot distributions I feel like um point
to um other takeaways that one can be in
their 70s and have testosterone levels
equivalent to a male and healthy male in
his 30s that one can be in their 30s and
have testosterone levels that are twice
as much or half as much as as AG match
cohort this kind of thing um I think
there there's value in that so um what
what other takeaways um uh arrived with
the data from the the penis length study
that perhaps we didn't we didn't hear
about like what what did you find most
interesting about about the data well
that there was any change over time you
know this was a fairly short uh study it
was probably about you know 30 years or
so um but we did find that penal length
has been increasing over time so um you
know that was just sort of fascinating
that we would see sort of in such a
short interval of time that there would
be a change number one but that we we'd
see a lengthening number two so you know
again similar to the concerns that arose
for these you know relatively short
period of time where you would see
changes in semen quality um you know it
suggests something sinister right it's
unlikely to be a genetic change because
that would take you know centuries
probably uh certainly several
Generations so fact that this happened
so quickly um was just
surprising um this brings to mind some
of work that I was involved in years ago
um when I was a master student I studied
um early organizing effects of hormones
on uh the brain and body and um I'm sure
this has been updated um since then but
um my recollection is that uh during
embryonic development males um are
exposed to a certain amount of Di hydr
testosterone not testosterone but
dihydrotestosterone which organizes the
brain male as they used to say now the
the verbiage around that would probably
be a little bit different but the idea
is that um males are born um with penile
tissue of course but then it's during
puberty that the same hormone
dihydrotestosterone then exerts an
activating effects on the genitals and
the genitals grow during puberty penis
length increases so assuming that the
study that you did was on males um post
puberty right I'm assuming it was um
then it would imply that something's
changing about the levels or the
signaling related to
dihydrotestosterone um how could that
happen um do we have any ideas about
what might be happening I mean this is
the opposite of environmental endocrine
disruptors preventing sperm from being
as you know high quality and numerous as
they could be or from you know or
Environmental factors either in utero or
post utero um suppressing testosterone
levels here we're talking about the
opposite effect we're talking about
dihydro testosterone levels presumably
being higher in males over the last 30
years and thereby longer penises right
so I mean I think there's different
conjectures that you could make about
why this could happen I mean it could be
you know maybe endocrine disrupting
chemicals you know in utero some early
exposure you know that some of the
mothers had to kind of androgenic
effects during the male programming
window that may have led to some longer
lengths um another hypothesis we had is
that if if males are going through
puberty earlier the earlier one goes
through puberty the longer length tends
to be so maybe that provides sort of
this link so earlier puberty tends to be
longer potentially means longer duration
exposure to
dihydrotestosterone longer penises right
yeah you may be surprised to not to know
you might not be surprised to know that
there is a uh subculture online I know
because they contacted me in
anticipation of this episode um of um
post puberal males who take a
combination of
dihydrotestosterone and low levels of
growth hormone in efforts to try and
increase their penile length and the the
um ones taking dihydrotestosterone
they're not taking pure dhg they're
taking things like
oxandrolone um which very closely mimics
the structure of DHT um they report um
some success um fortunately they did not
send me pictures um otherwise I would
have just forwarded them to you for your
next study um but this stuff is
happening um in post puberal Mal so um
it it all rests on this dihydro
testosterone hypothesis um I don't know
just a point of Interest yeah I don't
know it just physiologically it doesn't
make sense why that would work as you're
pointing out post pubertally and then
unless they're doing other things you
know some sort of stretching exercises
or call jelking but yeah I would not
recommend that thank you that was the
response I was looking for so um that
Community will be listening with um uh
open ears don't do
it as long as we're talking about DHT
dihydro testosterone um it's only fair
to discuss the drugs that many people
take to suppress dihydrotestosterone in
hopes to keep or grow their hair things
like finasteride dutasteride
um some maybe many not all people who
take these drugs particularly in oral
form experience um sexual dysfunction
issues um and other issues related to
suppressing DHT that said my
understanding is that these drugs are
also quite useful maybe even life-saving
in some cases for um staving off certain
forms of prostate
cancer what are your thoughts about
finasteride taster do you see people
coming into your clinic
who are having sexual dysfunction or
other types of issues because of their
hair or attempt to maintain or grow
their hair issues and um equally
important is that we talk about
so-called post finasteride syndrome I
got a lot of questions about post
finasterid syndrome um because I'll
describe it in a couple of minutes um it
sounds pretty devastating for these
people's lives um and I'll explain why
it's so devastating for them um in a
moment but you what about aside
dutasteride and these drugs that are
effectively DHT blockers um DHT levels
if they get too high indeed can
miniaturize the hair follicle cause
people to lose their hair typically up
front or in the back so-called crown or
whatever you know Widows Peak uh uh uh
or everywhere in some cases um it also
induces hair growth on the back beard
growth as we understand but then people
go and take these drugs to try and
maintain or grow their hair and often
times they have erectile dysfunction or
other issues isues is that surprising to
you you know I think the men that we see
these um these side effects are are tend
to be you know younger men in their 20s
30s and 40s uh and they' take it as
you're pointing out for hair loss so
before it was FDA approved for that
indication at least finasteride was you
know they did randomized control trials
to look um and one of the other things
that we we'll talk about too is just
reproductive effects so they did you
know lots of studies to see if there
were changes in semen quality you know
for men on finasteride versus the
placebo and there were some very subtle
changes but you know sort of in
postmarketing now we see these patients
in clinic um you know everybody to
enroll in these studies had normal
function so I think that's sort of
important to understand and obviously
that's not life right that people come
in with sort of different baselines and
different amounts of reserve and so we
now know that there's probably people
that are a lot more sensitive to these
medications than others and so there are
some men that drop their sperm counts
dramatically and usually if we're we
stop these medications their sperm CS
can recover you know usually a
spermatogenic cycle is probably about 2
to 3 months so usually in maybe 3 to 6
months we usually see recovery for most
men um but similarly for you know sexual
function I certainly you know have a
number of patients you know that do
complain of low libido erectile function
this post finasteride syndrome um you
know and the mechanisms I think are less
certain because you know measuring
testosterone levels which we do you know
sometimes if androgens are low or even
if androgens seem to be in the maybe
normal range or low normal range will
try and increase testosterone through a
variety of means testosterone chopine
sometimes will give you know it helps
some men but not all so I think the
exact mechanism of what is going on here
what is changing I think um you know we
need more you know more understanding
about the exact sort of path of
physiology um neur you know or
neurochemically it seems like a pretty
serious trade-off to either maintain to
grow hair or lose sexual function I mean
talked about DHT and some of these um
side effects of Finas do test ride on um
previous episodes and you know I'm not a
clinician but my encouragement is always
for people to approach these drugs with
a with a real level of seriousness if
not caution um the post finasteride
syndrome was described in these online
questions as seemingly permanent even
though um people had ceased to take
finasteride or dutasteride so in other
words they were taking this stuff they I
don't know how they felt while they were
on it but they stopped taking it and the
sexual dysfunction issues um don't seem
to be resolving um does that mean they
should go see uh you or another uh male
urologist reproductive health specialist
yeah I mean oftentimes they do for you
know these complaints um you know they
start to notice it when they're on the
medication then when they you know
usually through online research kind of
learn about this potential entity
sometimes they discontinue now some men
do have resolution when they stop but
there is this permanence in some handful
of men um you know they've done you know
MRI IM to try and understand sort of you
know more anatomically or functionally
what exactly is going on I think there's
still a lot of unknowns about it but it
can be you know permanent for some so
they come in you know and they see me in
clinic erec all dysfunction low libido
and then we go down all the the host of
treatments that we talked about in
evaluations that we talked about again
we have resolution in some but there are
some that seem treatment refractory
yikes that's my only response I
mean permanent effects uh on Sexual
Health in it as a consequence of an
attempt to maintain one's hair I mean
this is where you know um in all
seriousness it it it just sounds like
something that um people need to think
very seriously about because as I
understand there's nothing that can
predict whether or not someone will
have post finasteride syndrome right
right um and I did um a bit of reading
on this uh within the scientific
journals as well there isn't a lot of
information as you point out because
it's a fairly recent phenomenon and that
highlights a different issue
this may be the first time in history
where young males are taking finasteride
and dutasteride and that might be the
cause of the postfastr syndrome right I
think you you alluded to this earlier
right these drugs have proven to be very
beneficial for older men treating
prostate issues exactly yeah right so
this is a post finasterid syndrome um I
think falls under the category of
medical conditions that um you know a
few years ago we we would hear the same
about um chronic fatigue syndrome
even fibromyalgia not long ago was
considered one of these oh is it all a
psychosomatic issue now we we now
clearly know that's not the case for
fibromyalgia by the way um but I can
recall a time not that long ago when
people um in the medical profession kind
of like well yeah this I don't know if
this is a real thing but postfastr
syndrome sounds certainly real for the
people that are suffering from it
exactly yeah yeah okay well the reason
I'm spending so much time on this is
that um I get a lot of questions about
it and there clearly a lot of young
males who take fastrite or do tast ride
or are thinking of doing that um for
cosmetic reasons and I think they should
be aware of the potentially serious
consequences yeah agree yeah but you did
say earlier that if someone has a penis
you can get it hard so um so all is not
lost even for these post finasterid
syndromes individual good okay we'll
hold use that um you mentioned
chopine um could you explain what
chopine is and what it's used for um
because again uh we want this discussion
to be centered around the real science
the real medicine um but there is a
growing kind of subc commmunity of
people out there who are saying okay
testosterone therapy can cause us these
sperm um suppressive issues and perhaps
some other issues um but doing nothing
might not be an option for somebody who
wants to increase their whatever libido
other aspects of of um Androgen function
um and so there there are a growing
number of people out there who are
taking chopine only in order to
presumably increase testosterone but my
understanding is that it would impact
the estrogen pathway as well yeah what's
chopine uh what are your thoughts about
people using chopine um sort of off Lael
um simply to increase androgens seems
sketchy to me for reasons related to
changes in neural circuits um but you'll
tell us how it works then yeah well
thank you for including the offlab
closer anytime I talk about this I
always have to say say that but so
chopine is a selective estrogen receptor
modulator so basically it blocks
estrogen and so from our earlier
discussions of how the pituitary works
you know there's sort of an elaborate
feedback loop between the pituitary and
the gonads and the man the testes and so
what happens is you know FSH LH these
genotropin stimulate the testicle to
make sperm and testosterone
testosterones peripherally converted to
estrogen and that feeds back on the
hypothalamus to stop that so again you
don't get an over production so by
blocking the estrogen receptor the level
of the pituitary or the hypothalamus
you'll stop that and so the idea behind
blocking that is that you'll get more
production of FSH LH more of these
drivers so you get more testosterone you
get a higher stimulation of the testicle
you know the hope is that for fertility
that sometimes it can improve sperm
production too and there's some limited
data that can help um but I think as
you're alluding to it's sort of a way to
just augment your body's own production
of testosterone so it certainly does
that I think there's no question that
testosterone levels do rise I think that
the reason that doesn't always help is
because not every problem is solved by
testosterone we kind of talked about
somewhat in this uh this discussion but
also that you know you do need some
estrogenic signaling as well and so by
blocking that you know even partially
because there's also some partial
Agonist effects of chopine as well it
may limit it um and you know turns out
that estrogen signal is important for a
lot of things it's important for you
know bone health but sexual health too
it's important for libido so that may be
partially blunting some of the hope for
benefits of testosterone I found that
men tend to be happier on testosterone
than some of these other forms and that
could be a possible explanation um but
one of the advantage of chopine if we
are thinking about this is a treatment
for low testosterone hyperism is that it
doesn't have the same toxic effects on
sperm production so by maintaining the
body's own production of testosterone by
maintaining production of FSH LH will
continue to get sperm production so for
this reproductive man that has low
testosterone and symptomatic low
testosterone you know low you know low
energy level sex drive mood sleep
problems uh it can be a worthwhile
treatment and it it does help a lot of
men um but not
everybody I've always been curious why
if the goal is to increase sperm
production that the most common
treatment is HCG human chonic gadat
tropen because as you mentioned earlier
luteinizing hormone and FSH follicles
stimulating hormone um are deployed from
the pituitary and travel to the testes
where they stimulate um testosterone
production and sperm production but it's
the FSH specifically that encourages
sperm production so why wouldn't um a
man who's taking maybe testosterone
therapy or who perhaps just wants
increased sperm C in quality take FSH
instead of human chonic Gat tropin which
is more or less a proxy for luteinizing
that's a really good question and so
what FSH does like you said is it
stimulates sperm production so it seems
like it'd be a much more logical
treatment and actually in randomized
Placebo control trials it does do that
so one of the reason it does do that it
does help okay so it's beneficial and we
should we should give it more but one of
the reasons that we don't is cost so
it's rarely covered by insurance and HCG
a month of that is in the hundreds of
dollars so let's say like $300 to $500
but a month of sort of therapeutic FSH
is probably $2 to $3,000
so that cost is really limiting it takes
two to three months to make a sperm so
um you know men often have to be would
have to be on it for several months but
there is reasonable data that would help
and it does make you know a lot more
sense that that should be given as adant
therapy with testosterone rather than
HCG um but HD does work you know sort of
everyone's surprised it does actually
help um but yeah I agree there is sort
of a contradiction there so if the price
came down it doesn't you know this is
another off Lael medication for that
indication um it would be it could be
worthwhile
one hormone that we haven't discussed is
Prolactin um I'm familiar with prolactin
from a variety of perspectives but um I
always think of uh dopamine and
prolactin is kind of a seesaw
relationship dopamine's up prolactin is
down you know dopamine is elevated with
sexual desire sexual activity post
ejaculation prolactin goes up sets
perhaps the refractory period on
erection ejaculation for some period of
time then dopamine comes back up but you
know this kind of thing and I realize
that's far too simplistic that prolactin
is doing many things in the brain and
body besides that but how often do you
see
hyperprolactinemia um I don't know if
plural Pras is uh is clinically correct
but um elevated levels of prolactin that
are causing
problems um for men um what are some of
the telltale signs of that um and this
I'd like to use as a segue to talking
about um some of the sexual dysfunction
that is commonly discussed around the
use of SS I and other other drugs to
treat depression and and mental health
issues that sometimes create um
endocrine and or sexual health issues
yeah so prolactin um is sometimes it's a
diagnosis hyperprolactinemia it's a
diagnosis make not that many times I
would say you know less than 1% of the
patients that we see will end up having
that but usually it's a handful of times
a year because you know we see a lot of
patients um typically the The Telltale
sort of symptoms would be you know ones
of low testosterone that's a common one
but you know in my practice I see it a
lot with men with very low sperm
production so I've diagnosed several
prolactin secreting tumors and the
manifestation of that was you know they
weren't getting pregnant we checked the
sperm count it was very low you know
that mandates a check of testosterone
which is also very low and then that
leads to a prolactin which is very high
and then that that was diagnosed so it's
something I think to be aware of but I
don't know that there's not usually a
lot of symptoms and sort of going to a
clinician when having sexual dysfunction
symptoms low testosterone or fertility
problems will usually you know be able
to diagnose it if it's present are there
any other hormones in the um in the
galaxy of sexual health related hormones
that uh fall into uh you know Common
clinical practice uh for you um I check
estrogen as well so I think that's
another one is again because of the
relationship with obesity I think that
can be important sometimes there's too
much aromatization and so sometimes uh
that can be a problem I think just like
we talked about normal estrogen
signaling is important I think too much
can be bad so there are some men where
we you see manifestations that can
manifest as gynecomastia in some cases
male breast tissue male breast tissue
yeah as I was um told um what was it
that the uh male breast tissue is sort
of like um the appendix it's there but
it's not very interesting right right
yeah everybody has some and we just
don't want the growth to get out of
control could you tell us about one of
the world's most difficult to pronounce
words which is
verical yes so verical it's a very
common condition probably about 15% of
all men have it and it's a very common
cause of infertility if you look at all
the ideologies it can be 30 to 40% so
basically what it is is dilated veins in
the scrotum um so obviously we need
veins to get blood out of the testicles
U but sometimes they can be a little
larger than average and there's sort of
a normal sort of thermal regulation so
if the veins get too big it's thought to
warm up the testicle the other thought
is that it doesn't adequately clear some
of the metabolites um so exactly the
pathophysiology is you know somewhat
debated but I think those probably
contribute um and it's something that
everybody should be evaluated for if
you're concerned about fertility um so
again we see it very commonly you know
given the fact that a lot of men have it
about one in seven men have it it
doesn't always cause a problem but maybe
about 20 to 25% of the time it does so
men will manifest with low sperm counts
we see sometimes discomfort you know
ache you know worse at the end of the
day than at the beginning worse of
activity anytime blood can pool
sometimes it stretches and some men feel
that and then in kids sometimes it can
lead to um either stunted testicular
growth or shrinkage of the testicle um
it's also thought to be a progressive
lesion so the longer a man has it the
more damage it can do it usually
manifests around puberty in general um
so it's not a concern for everybody but
I think certainly if couples are having
difficulty conceiving you're having
discomfort in the area and you have one
it's a discussion you should
have what about ponis disease yes so
ponis is a scar baring of the penis
which leads to curvature or deformity so
the way erections work is everything
swells and you can imagine if there's a
scar tissue it doesn't swell
symmetrically so you'll get like a
curvature deviation sometimes you can
get an hourglass or sort of a banding um
if you look it up on the internet you
can see you know a host of different
deformities that men get it probably
present in about 5 to 10% of men so it's
very common um sometimes it could be
from injury you know from you know a
like a penal fracture other you know
sort of less severe form of injury to
the penis sometimes men have described
hitting it on different things
potentially that could could lead to it
sometimes it can manifest after
um prostate cancer surgery or other kind
of surgeries which can you know sort of
stun the penis or you know injure some
of the nerves of the penis um so that's
another condition we see commonly um you
know obviously it can lead to bother you
know and erections are not straight that
can just you know cause um you know
psychologic bother to men it can can
also physically make it difficult for a
man to have sex you know um sometimes it
can limit certain positions so that's
another common complaint we see um I
think it's something that men should be
aware of there's now awareness campaigns
now that there's an FDA approved
medicine for it uh collagenase or zlex
which is a medicine that disolves scar
tissue um so that's one of the
treatments we have for it there's also
you know different devices sort of
stretching devices where we try and just
mechanically remodel the penis to allow
it to be a little bit straighter um and
then there's also surgical options too
so there's a lot we can do I always tell
men again as long as we have a penis we
can make it we can make it hard but we
can also make it
straight I'm wondering why in the study
about penis length uh testicular size
and volume wasn't also measured and and
that's something that we haven't
discussed um what is the relationship
between testicular size and volume um
and some of the other parameters we've
been talking about and maybe this is
also a good time to highlight um
any kind of um morphological signals
that uh would warrant people coming to
the clinic so asymmetry in testical size
for instance um changes in testicular
size um obviously a psize lump uh they
taught us in uh High School is um a
warning sign of potential testicular
tumor or cancer um yeah we didn't really
talk about testicles yeah so I think
that yeah kind of being aware you know
the average size of um a testicle for a
man is about you know sort of about a
walnut so it's about 16 to 20
CC's um you usually if you're going to
measure it it' be about four to four and
a half centimeters and longest axis to
give you know your listeners or viewers
some idea um if it changes certainly let
people know if you feel anything let
people know although um our uh you know
National guidelines on screening
practices recommends against regular
testicular self- exams interestingly
because I think the concern is that it
leads to more anxiety than cancers that
it would diagnose but I think you know I
always tell men no one knows your
scrotum better than you so if you
identify you know problem you should
bring it to attention so you know the
classic appearance or the way that a
testos cancer would manifest is a firm
painless mass that you kind of feel
coming from the testicle um I find it
interesting that um at least as I
understand women are encouraged to do
regular self- exams of their breasts for
for lumps so but you're telling me that
men are discouraged from doing regular
exams of their testicles for lumps that
could be cancer that feels like a um
unfair
asymmetry it does I mean Cancer I mean
both both seem very important um oh yeah
well I think there's no question
obviously I'm very biased yeah yeah I
was trying to say it so you didn't have
to right oh yeah I don't want to get in
trouble with the US I don't want anyone
to get cancer I mean I so um I don't
even want a dog to get cancer um so I'm
surprised that they discourage self-
exam
um but is it because men are getting it
wrong they're coming into the clinic
thinking they have testicular cancer and
then most of the time they don't I think
that's the concern that you know the
number of cancers that are diagnosed
versus the false you know um the false
you know lumps that they identify just
lead to more anxiety and end up not
actually you know causing more harm than
good I think is the concern but um yeah
it was a surprising recommendation when
it came down usually if patients ask
about it I certainly don't discourage
them from doing these exams and I have
we've certainly identified cancers
through that means before well I saw the
episode of er where the guy was having
trouble breathing when he was an elite
Runner and it turned out he had
testicular cancer and he had overlooked
the lump on his testicle so I'm going to
continue to self-screen okay fair enough
numerous times today we've talked about
the potential benefit of getting a blood
test for hormone profiles lipid profiles
and other things as well as a sperm
analysis um my understanding is that one
can only do that if they have the
disposal I income to elect to do that
through some commercial online service
um but is there any way that um patients
who have insurance can uh approach their
physician in a way that this would be
covered by Insurance um I don't want to
get you into any trouble here but I you
know it's it's always such a shame it is
such a shame when we're talking about
something that is really um per
pervasively related to health has his
Sexual Health reproductive health and
people are not aware of a potential
problem in the present or in the future
that could have been mitigated simply
because they didn't get a blood test or
do something as simple as a um a sperm
analysis um so we can't be presumptuous
and saying oh well you know two $200 or
$1,000 is no big deal I mean for a lot
of people that's a huge deal right um
it's prohibitive um for many people so
how can people get this stuff assessed
um should they talk to their primary
care physician should they um call a
urologist what's the best approach yeah
I think both are good strategies I think
you know insurance is becoming a lot
more open to covering some infertility
at least testing sometimes treatment as
well so I think a lot of insurance does
cover that now you know sometimes we
check cement analyses for other Jacory
issues um but I think that you know
again as more of this data gets out I
think as more recognition how important
the mail is I think we'll get um sort of
more buying and coverage obviously women
have you know the automatic feedback of
obory Cycles so they kind of know and if
there's a problem they can bring that to
the attention but men don't have that
feedback without some of these testing
yeah and we probably should have
mentioned this earlier so forgive me I I
this was on me to mention that when we
talk about sperm quality and we sort of
shifted back and forth to semen quality
it's possible to have um normal semen
volume and have very low sperm count
right we're not talking about the total
amount of ejaculate per se we're talking
about the density of forwardly motile
healthy non-dna fragmented sperm in that
semen right so in other words it's not
sufficient to just um assume because uh
you can ejaculate that your sperm are
healthy that's exactly right yeah I mean
I think you know about 15% of men have
low Seamon quality whether it be
concentration movement shape about 1% of
men have no sperm in the ejaculate and
that's something sometimes they have no
idea about so the only way to know would
be to actually do a formal test well I'm
encouraging people um to get these
parameters assessed and I'm I'm making
that statement um because it's very
clear based on everything that you've
told us today that sperm quality and
hormone levels are just oh so important
um not just for sexual health um but for
urinary health and for reflecting
prostate health and other aspects of
whole body health and and um Sexual
Health relates um directly to mental
health right we we didn't talk so much
about the psychogenic issues but um the
two go hand inand EXA I want to thank
you so much for coming here today and
sharing so much knowledge with us I mean
these really are the issues that um
males think about and wonder about and
um have questions about um and they do
so to varying degrees depending on where
they're at in life um but I think
especially for younger men who are
hearing this um who are not at the point
where they want to conceive um it's
really important to start thinking about
these issues for all the all the reasons
you mentioned I think these issues are
really important um for women to know
about as well just as it's important for
men to understand uh female reproductive
health and and uh to not just improve
communication but this after all um is
at the heart of the uh the presence and
proliferation of our species so thanks
for taking care of the male half and um
uh and thanks for doing the work you do
it's incredible um the large scale
studies the the more detailed the
studies the um on smaller populations
the you ask the questions that it seems
um many people are just afraid to ask
and and you get right in there and and
come out with the the really rigorous
data and answer so thank you so much for
what you do my pleasure thank you thank
you for highlighting men's reproductive
Health thank you for joining me for
today's discussion with Dr Michael
Eisenberg to learn more about his
research and his clinical practice
please check out the links in the show
note captions if you're learning from
and or enjoying this podcast please
subscribe to our YouTube channel that's
a terrific zeroc cost way to support us
in addition please subscribe to the
podcast on both Spotify and apple and on
both Spotify and apple you can leave us
up to a five-star review please also
check out the sponsors mentioned at the
beginning and throughout today's episode
that's the best way to support this
podcast if you have questions for me or
comments about the podcast or guests
that you'd like me to consider hosting
on the huberman Lab podcast please put
those in the comment section on YouTube
I do read all the comments not during
today's episode but on many previous
episodes of the the hubman Lab podcast
we discuss supplements while supplements
aren't necessary for everybody many
people derive tremendous benefit from
them for things like enhancing sleep
hormone support and improving Focus if
you'd like to learn more about the
supplements discussed on the hubman Lab
podcast you can go to live momentus
spelled o us so Liv mous.com
huberman if you're not already following
me on social media it's huberman lab on
all social media platforms so that's
Instagram Twitter now called X threads
Facebook LinkedIn and on all those
places I discuss science and science
related tools some of which overlaps
with the content of the huberman Lab
podcast but much of which is distinct
from the content on the huberman Lab
podcast so again it's huberman lab on
all social media platforms if you
haven't already subscribed to our
monthly neural network newsletter the
neural network newsletter is a
completely zero cost newsletter that
gives you podcast summaries as well as
toolkits in the form of brief PDFs we've
had tool kits related to optimizing
sleep to regulating dopamine deliberate
cold exposure Fitness mental health
learning and neuroplasticity and much
more again it's completely zero cost to
sign up you simply go to hubman lab.com
go over to the menu tab scroll down to
newsletter and Supply your email I
should emphasize that we do not share
your email with anybody thank you once
again for joining me for today's
discussion with Dr Michael Eisenberg and
last but certainly not least thank you
for your interest in
[Music]
science